[Musique]
Denis Robert, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
euh
me présenter aujourd'hui. Il y a il y a
quelques temps, j'aurais dit euh que je
suis euh le le directeur d'une
rédaction. Aujourd'hui, je peux plus
dire ça. Je suis mais j'ai toujours et
je suis toujours avant tout écrivain.
Euh j'ai 62 ans,
j'habite pas Paris.
Euh et là, je je suis heureux d'être là.
Euh je suis d'abord parce que ça me fait
plaisir de de vous voir et puis c'est je
crois que je dois être un des un des
invités les plus les plus assus
puisqueen en une dizaine d'années, je
crois que c'est la 4e fois, j'ai essuyé
les plâtres avec toi tout au début. Donc
c'est toujours un plaisir de de te voir
et puis de suivre aussi vos émissions
quoi. Et je suis surtout là aujourd'hui
pour parce que j'ai écrit cet été
j'ai écrit cet été un livre qui
s'appelle Larry et moi euh dont le
sous-titre est comment Black Rock nous
aime, nous surveille et nous détruit.
Euh Larry étant Larry Fink le patron de
de Black Rock et Black Rock étant une
sans doute euh la multinationale la plus
euh la plus puissante du monde. On
pourra s'expliquer ensuite sur les
raisons de cette puissance. Alors nous
nous on t'a fait revenir parce que
certes tu as essuyé les plâtres et puis
tu nous as donné aussi de la motivation
pour pouvoir
enquêter, former une communauté, former
à détecter des sources de bonne qualité
et tu nous as tu nous as vraiment donné
beaucoup de motivation et de force et on
t'a connu à travers Clearstream, une
enquête qui a duré des années, une
décennie, plus d'une décennie et et où
tu enquêtais sur les paradis fiscaux et
l'évasion fiscale. Aujourd'hui, le
bouquin sur Black Rock, ça nous
intéresse beaucoup. Euh euh qu'est-ce
qui t'a poussé à enquêter sur une un
fond d'investissement qui est légal, qui
emploie un peu moins de 15000 salariés,
qui gère 6000 milliards de dollars
peu plus
qui un peu plus euh ça peut même
beaucoup plus
même genre 15000 milliards sur
non, c'est pas ça. C'estàd que en fond
propre, ils ont ils ont 8000 milliards.
Et ce qui passe euh par Aladin, le leur
leur intelligence artificielle, c'est 30
300 milliards, 31000 milliards. On
rentrera dans les détails de
l'intelligence artificielle pour la pour
la suite.
Donc on a décidé de te faire venir pour
nous expliquer en fait le principe de
Black Rock,
une société belle sous toutes les
coutures,
qui gère les retraites de beaucoup de de
petits épargnants et qui a peut-être une
tendance systémique.
Qu'est-ce que c'est une une tendance
systémique ?
Et c'est bien que tu m'es parlé
Clearstream, j'ai pas envie de revenir
sur Clearstream, mais j'ai ressenti la
même sensation
de de
comment dire d'importance pour moi de
témoigner avec Black Rock que je l'ai
ressenti au moment de Clairstream. Euh
il y avait il y avait comme une
nécessité de d'écrire. Et mon histoire
avec Black Rock est aussi liée à mon
histoire avec Larifing et et est liée à
Clearstream. CLAM, c'était gigantesque.
C'était une chambre de compensation qui
qui faisait du on va dire de de de
du transfert de fonds d'un pays à
l'autre. Enfin, pour faire pour faire
cour, c'était la la la banque des
banques. Et moi, petit journaliste, je
suis tombé là-dessus et il y a eu ces 10
années de procédure. Et là, mes
activités au médias, enfin tout ce que
j'ai fait ces ces dernières années m'ont
m'ont un peu fait décrocher de la
finance. Mais la reifing est pour moi
presque un nom commun. C'estàd que pour
les gens et les les gens ne savent pas
qui est Laurence Fing et moi je sais je
sais qui il est parce que euh après euh
pendant pendant la disons pendant la fin
de Clearstream, je me suis retrouvé dans
une j'étais un peu démonétisé, j'étais
devenu une sorte de paria au niveau des
journalistes et je me suis retrouvé dans
une je je lisais je je lisais beaucoup
de livres sur la finance alors que je
suis absolument pas journaliste
financier. C'est sans doute ce qui fait
ma force. C'est-à-dire que quand je suis
face à un monstre comme Black Rock ou à
une énigme comme celle de Larifing, je
l'approche avec mes armes à moi qui sont
si je comprends pas, je pose des
questions, je réfléchis, je vais aux
sources et cetera. Et donc la reifing,
je je savais qui il était
euh parce que il était dans tous les
mauvais coûts de la finance et du de la
private equity au niveau de de toutes
les grosses boîtes américaines des
banques. Pourquoi qualifie ça de mauvais
coup ? C'est légal. Oui, c'est c'est
légal mais euh c'est des mauvais coups
parce que ce sont des gens qui sont euh
tu sais la question à se poser, c'est
comment des économies aussi riches que
les nôtres produisent autant de pauvreté
? Et c'est parce qu'il y a des
prédateurs comme Larifing ou comme ses
fonds de pension américain qui viennent.
C'est toi qui l'appelle prédateur.
Noup piller, pardon,
c'est toi qui l'appelle prédateur.
Oui, c'est c'est de la prédation. Je
peux je peux c'est c'est 300 pages qui
qui l'expliquent et qui je pense le le
démontrent. Donc Larryfing, quand je le
vois arriver euh euh après l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron, il faut il faut
savoir que euh quand Macron a été élu,
le premier type, les deux premiers types
qui viennent lui le féliciter et le voir
à l'Élysée, mais avant les industriels,
avant les banquiers français, c'est
Jean-François Cirelli, le PDG de la
branche française de de Black Rock et
Larif qui arrive à à l'Élysée euh et qui
rencontre Macron.
C'est c'est peut-être bien, non ? Je me
fais je me fais entre guillemets la
vocale. Non mais Macron Macron Emmanuel
Macron va expliquer que c'est très
intéressant de de se faire bien voir de
la refing parce que ça permet à des
capitaux euh euh américains et à à Black
Rock d'investir en France puisque depuis
euh 2017, je crois qu'il y a 100
milliards 160 milliards de de dollars de
Black Rock qui sont venus dans les
sociétés du 440 pour financer des boîtes
et cetera. Donc c'est un afflux d'argent
dans ce sens. On peut se dire "OK, c'est
intéressant d'avoir Black Rock comme
partenaire." Aujourd'hui, Black Rock, ça
représente à peu près 4 % du CAC 40.
C'est-à-dire si tu prends les 40
sociétés françaises, les le côté en
bourse, tu as 4 % qui appartiennent à
Black Rock. Total, Sanofi,
euh euh enf à un moment donné, je enfin
je sais pas par quel bout je peux le
prendre, mais j'aime bien raconter cette
anecdote qui te dit le l'importance de
Black Rock. Avant avant avant que tu tu
commences à faire l'anédocte,
je me fais l'avocat du diable. Notre
président charismatique euh invite un
des leaders de fond d'investissement
pour prendre conseil.
H
c'est bien, c'est il a des résultats ce
garsl et et et il va peut-être aider la
France.
Je pense pas qu'il va aider la France.
Je pense qu'il va couler la France et je
pense qu'il est en train de le faire. Et
euh d'ailleurs, je dédie mon livre au au
aux militants de d'extinction rébellion
qui ont qui ont tagué le le siège de
Black Rock à Paris euh parce que c'est
un réel danger. Black Rock,
tu cautionnes ça
complètement.
Pourquoi ?
Bah parce qu'à un moment un moment c'est
tout ça ça se passe. C'estàd que le
grand public a pas conscience des dégâts
que que provoque Black Rock. C'est
c'est une raison c'est une raison c'est
une raison pour aller
mais parce qu'il y a pas il y a pas
d'aut il y a pas d'autres moyens. En
plus, ils ont pas été une raison c'est
une raison pour aller faire une kermè
dans les locaux de Black Rock pour aller
emmerder.
Ça ça permet de de parler de Black Rock
de de poser à un moment tu as plus de tu
as plus d'autres moyens puisque les
grands médias on parle pas. Pourquoi je
fais le livre ? C'est pour ça aussi
c'est parce que c'est sous les radars
l'arrifing et Black Rock. Chaque fois
que tu tu lis un papier sur la refing,
c'est toujours les mêmes conneries quoi.
C'est-à-dire le type il va au boulot à
6h, il se couche à 18h, sa femme lui
fait des pancakes, il laissé le bon père
de famille et cetera. Puis quand tu
grattes un peu, tu tu vois que c'est pas
du tout ça. C'est le plus gros tueur que
Wall Street tueur entre guillemets hein.
Il a et et jamais pu produire quoi. Et
c'est aussi l'homme le plus puissant de
Wall Street aujourd'hui. Et l'ascension
de Larifing, elle est absolument
fascinante. C'estd qu'au début des il y
a plein d'entrées dans cette histoire
mais
son père était marchand de chaussures.
Voilà, son père était marchand de
chaussures. Sa mère était prof
d'anglais. lui fait des études de de
commercial à Los Angeles et puis et puis
très vite, il rentre à la First Boston
qui est une qui est une banque où il
fait sa place et c'est un des un des
premiers à à se lancer dans les crédits
hypothécaires, enfin tout ce qui est
l'immobilier et cetera. Et il il gagne
plein d'argent, c'est un trader, il
gagne plein de blé
légalement.
Légalement. Non non mais c'est toujours
ces mecs, c'est comme c'est les types
qui font de l'optimisation fiscale,
c'est toujours légal. Mais en tout cas,
lui il gagne il gagne beaucoup d'argent
jusqu'au jour où il fait perdre 100
millions de dollars à la first Boston
parce qu'il voit pas venir la la c'est
c'était les prémisses de de de ce qui
arrivera 15 ans plus tard avec la crise
des subcriprime. Il il voit il voit pas
venir ça et il fait perdre 100 millions
de de dollars. Donc il va se retrouver
dans un placard, il va voir une
traversée du désert mais ça ça le forme
à à au calcul du risque. C'est-à-dire
que LARF est un type qui est obsédé par
le risque et dès le départ quand il
ensuite il va voir il va voir deux
banquiers enfin il se passe 3 4 ans et
il rencontre deux gros banquiers
milliardaires qui s'appellent Peterson
et Schwarzman. D'ailleurs, ça s'appelle
Black Rock parce que
au départ ça s'appelait euh
enf en fait Peterson c'est la pierre et
Schwartzman, c'est le noir. Donc c'était
la pierre noire. Après, c'est devenu le
le le rocher noir. Donc, l'origine du
nom Black Rock vient de là. Et les deux
types lui filent un peu d'argent et il
commence à créer son fond euh
d'investissement. Et donc euh il va
commencer à gagner beaucoup d'argent, il
va se séparer d'eux et dès le départ,
c'est-à-dire il développe cette idée
qu'il faut créer une intelligence
artificielle et il faut capter sur le
monde entier, sur la planète euh toutes
les informations finanes informations
possibles
pour pour renseigner. il fait du data
avant l'heure, c'est-à-dire que quand il
commence, alors ce qui est très
intéressant, c'est que il il a il a un
immense hangar avec un millier
d'ordinateurs qui moulin en permanence
depuis 20 ans sur le fleuve Columbia
dans une ville qui s'appelle Wchibi où
il y avait il y avait que des pommiers
et des des mangeurs de pommes avant que
lui arrive. Et il fait ça là-bas parce
que parce que le Columbia est un fleuve
où il y a beaucoup de barrages et tu et
c'est l'électricité la moins chère des
États-Unis. Donc lui, ça fait 20 ans que
la moindre information, il la il la
collecte et qui se sert de ces
informations-là dans un une intelligence
artificielle qui s'appelle Aladin. Et
toute la planète financière et mais
aussi des grosses boîtes comme Apple ou
la BCE ou des des des pays comme la
Grèce ou comme l'Irlande se connecte à à
Black Rock et à Aladin pour récupérer de
l'information en vue de leurs
investissements.
Il se connectent moyen finances
évidemment. Donc Black Rock, faut dire
que Black Rock est une des boîtes qui
gagne qui est les plus lucratives de de
de enfin je veux dire, je crois qu'en
fond propre, ils ont 14 milliards et ils
font 5 milliards de BF, ce qui est enfin
les les je cite ça de mémoire, je me
trompe peut-être d'un ou 2 milliards,
c'est pas grave, on retrouve les infos
dans le dans le livre. Mais voilà, Black
Rock, c'est ça. Et dans il y a un truc
que je raconte dans le livre qui est
assez révélateur de l'importance que
Black Rock a en France. Je raconte une
soirée chez mon père. Je bouffe une fois
par semaine chez mon père et pour aller
chez lui, je prends l'autoroute, je paye
du péage. Il a une télé Samsung, on
regarde Canal Plus, on boit du Bordeaux,
il fait des petits poids. Et tu fais
attention avec le Covid et ton père ?
Oui, je fais très attention. Non mais
c'est sûr mais c'est pas ça. C'estàd que
tu tu décryptes une soirée comme ça et
tu vois que tout ce que tu as fait dans
la soirée, le péage, prendre de
l'essence totale, arriver dans une
bagnole de marque. En l'occurrence c'est
une Jaguar mais c'est tata, c'est une
vieille Jaguar que j'ai mes bon pass
duel, la télé Samsung Canal Plus Black
Rock possède au moins 5 ou 6 % de de
toutes ces boîtes et exerce aujourd'hui
une influence très forte.
Est-ce que tu tiens tes informations de
6 % ? tu vas tu vas tu vas sur internet,
tu tapes Black Rock, tu tu trouves ça
assez facilement quoi. Et aujourd'hui,
Black Rock est omniprésent, omnipuissant
en France. Et il faut voir que si tu
veux, c'est la première chose peut-être
que j'aurais dû dire, c'est-à-dire que
ils font à la fois du du de de de
l'investissement et ils font du conseil
et comment dire la refing essaie de nous
faire croire qu'il y a une sorte de
muraille de Chine entre ces deux
activités alors que c'est faux. Alors
que il y a il y a il y a des moments où
les les uns et les autres se se
s'interpénètre. Donc ça peut provoquer
des séismes euh
sur la planète financière et et à notre
niveau quoi. Parce que ça ils ont gagné
tellement d'argent, ils en gagnent
tellement qu'à un moment donné si tu
veux ce genre de boîte le le la bourse
c'est une sorte de casino géant où c'est
toujours le dernier qui mise qui qui
emporte la mise quoi. Et et Black Rock
est devenu tellement puissant, brasse
tellement d'argent qu'ils sont chaque
fois obligés de trouver des nouveaux
marchés. Et là pourquoi ils viennent en
France et pourquoi Larifing vient en
France si souvent ? Une des révélations
d'ailleurs du du livre, c'est que c'est
qu'il est venu à il est venu à huit
reprises
de tes révélations.
Une de mes révélation,
c'est qu'il est venu à huit reprises en
France et qu'il a rencontré plusieurs
fois
Emmanuel Macron et lui c'est c'est un
énorme lobbyiste qui veut absolument que
on on ait une retraite par
capitalisation. Donc c'est un pour
l'instant Black Rock possède 1 ou 2 % de
tout ce qui est euh euh euh argent de
des retraites. Il y a des AXA euh traite
beaucoup plus d'argent que que Black
Rock. Mais ils vont monter en puissance
et eux leur intérêt c'est chaque fois de
trouver des nouveaux marchés financiers
et chaque fois et chque euh gratter où
où il peut gratter de l'argent quoi.
Donc le l'aspect systémique de de Black
Rock, on l'aura compris, c'est toig to
fail. Ouais, c'est ça.
Ça veut dire trop gros pour se casser la
figure.
Ouais. Et et ils ont ils ont euh c'est
les premiers à avoir commercialisé ce
qu'on appelle des ETF.
Alors, avant de rentrer dans dans ce
détail de de
des fonds négociés en bourse, Ouais. Euh
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand une banque
systémique ou une ou un fond privé
systémique se se ce passe-moi
l'expression se vautre ? Bah, c'est les
mêmes brossers l'int l'int
de de ça sur le système financier.
Est-ce que ça peut secouer ? On sait que
pour les banques, l'État en général euh
euh recapitalise
sur un fond privé d'une boîte privée.
Est-ce qu'on peut faire ça ? Est-ce que
les États peuvent donner de l'argent ?
Donc qu'est-ce qui se passerait si par
exemple si par exemple si par exemple
on se tapait une petite épidémie
qui génerait euh des un séisme sur les
marchés financiers que ce type de boîte
se retrouve en short. Qu'est-ce qui se
passe ? C'est très compliqué que que
Black Rock se retrouve en en short parce
que euh il y a il y a des freins dans
les bourse qui qui qui font que c'est
euh si veux c'est impossible quasiment
de de que que Black Rock se retrouve en
short. Par contre par contre les gens
qui investissent dans Black Rock peuvent
se retrouver en short. Il y a il y a un
type j'ai découvert un article que les
initiés connaissent d'un type qui
s'appelle Michael Burry. Michael Burry,
c'est le c'est le héros de de Big Shot,
le le film, c'est celui qui a prévu
avant tout le monde, vraiment avant tout
le monde, la crise des subprime. C'est
un mathématicien, il avait fait des
calculs, il s'était rendu compte que les
que les fonds hypothécaires aux
États-Unis, ça allait provoquer un
séisme puisque on avait poussé les gens
à faire des crédits, des crédits, des
crédits. À un moment donné, ça allait
s'effondrer. Ça a été un des premiers à
alerter. On le voit d'ailleurs dans le
film. Le film est génial pour ça.
C'est quelle année ?
C'est 2007 quand il commence même 2006
quand il commence à alerter. On con on
connaitt un ancien trader français qui
s'appelle Jean-Manuel Rosan qui
qui a écrit un bouquin qui s'appelle Le
fric
et il en parle dedans.
Il parle de Michael Burry ?
Non, il parle de de de des empreintes
hypothécies la la que représentant un
très très grand risque.
Bah oui. Non mais c'estàdire que Berry
elle elle est le premier après il y en a
eu d'autres mais personne le croyait. Tu
tous les tous les banquiers de Mary
Lynch de Godman Sax et tout ça qui
disait mais c'est quoi ces conneries ça
ça coulera jamais et cetera. Et Burry
l'année dernière, enfin en septembre
2019, il a fait un papier euh je il a il
a il a fait une interview dans une
télévision américaine où il dit que le
plus grand danger aujourd'hui de la
planète financière à côté duquel la
crise des des subprimes sera presque une
plaisanterie, c'est Black Rock et les
ETF. Les ETF, c'est des fonds négociés
en bourse. C'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui
sur le Standard Purse qui est la
l'équivalent du CAC 40 sur les 500 plus
grandes sociétés américaines, plus de la
moitié de ce qui se commerce sur les
grandes sociétés américaines, enfin tout
ce qui s'investit en bourse américaine,
ce sont des ETF et ce sont plus des
actions. Et le Z ETF, c'est assez
compliqué à expliquer ce que j'ai mis du
temps à à à comprendre. Moi aussi, ils
appellent ça des fonds négociés en
bourse. Par exemple, euh tu peux le
prendre sur le CAC 40 plutôt que
d'investir, d'acheter des actions total
et cetera, tu vas avoir 10000 €. Tu es
tu es tu as un peu de fric, tu es
retraité et tu vas dire bon ben je vais
je vais prendre des ETF sur le CAC 40.
Et donc Black Rock va va
diviser par 40 tes investissements et va
[__] ça sur le le CAC 40. Si le CAC 40
monte, bah toi tu vas gagner de
l'argent, s'il ba en perdre et cetera.
Mais c'est une manière indifférenciée
d'aller d'aller d'aller vers la bourse.
Et ça ber explique que euh en achetant
des ETF, tu triches en fait sur les
indices boursiers. C'est-à-dire que les
il y en a tellement des ETF que les
indices boursiers ne veulent plus rien
dire. Et donc il y a des disparités
entre des petites boîtes et des grosses
boîtes. Des grosses boîtes comme Apple
et tout ça auront jamais de problème et
des petites boîtes peuvent crever assez
facilement si il y a il y a une crise du
Covid ou s'il y a des s'il y a des des
des aléas extérieurs qui interfèrent
là-dessus. Euh euh Berry donne donne une
image qui je trouve assez juste. Il dit
"On est comme dans un cinéma où il y a
plein de monde où il y a qu'une sortie.
à un moment donné, s'il y a un incendie
ou s'il se passe quelque chose, tout le
monde va vouloir sortir, c'est-à-dire
vendre ses actions et ceux qui vont
rester dans la salle de cinéma vont
crever parce que enfin vont crever
symboliquement parce qu'ils ils pourront
pas les vendre. Ça c'est le le le
résultat des ETF et Berry le le nous met
en garde tous contre ça et il il est un
peu ridiculisé. C'est un peu la même
chose qui se passe au niveau de 2008. Et
donc moi je me suis intéressé à ça. J'ai
commencé à essayer de réfléchir assez
naïvement. Peut-être que les les comment
dire les journalistes financiers que je
vont vont vont me trouver ridicule, mais
je suis pas le seul. Je cite des des des
analystes financiers qui qui partagent
ces vues ou plutôt que j'ai retrouvé et
qui disent la même chose puisque moi je
suis tombé sur Black Rock. Je suis tombé
sur Black Rock. Le point de départ de
tout ça, faut faut sans doute que j'en
j'en parle parce que c'est le plus
important. Pourquoi je me décide
d'écrire ce livre ?
La jeunesse de ça, c'est septembre 2019.
Je suis devant ma télévision et je
regarde un documentaire sur É, sur Black
Rock. Je crois que ça s'appelait les
financiers qui dirigent le monde. Je le
sous-titre du documentaire. Le
documentaire est effrayant parce qu'il
révèle mais il est il est très
compliqué. Mais je vois revenir Larryf.
Il y a une il y a enfin je pourrais en
parler après. Il y a des scènes. Il y a
une scène bon je peux en parler
d'ailleurs tout de suite ça ça va camper
le personnage. Il y a une scène qui est
absolument génial et mémorable dans le
documentaire, c'est qu' il va retrouver
un un extrait d'une émission de télé où
on voit la ref dans un fauteuil à côté
d'un d'un milliardaire qui s'appelle
Carl Ikan. Ikan, c'est celui qui a
inspiré le personnage de Gordon Jacko
dans Wall Street, le film d'Oliver
Stone. Et alors, d'habitude, ces gens-là
sont de bonne compagnie. discute enfin
tu vois il y a il y a il a y a ils ont
des des rapports cordion on va dire et
là il can il part en vri et il commence
à le le le l'animateur lui dit mais
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de Black Rock
de la Rifing et cetera et le mec le mec
il réfléchit il dit vous savez la refing
ça me ça me fait penser à un conducteur
de bus un bus qui dévalerait une pente
en folie il est il est au volant à côté
de
poussé par Jeanette Hélène. Comment
poussé par Jeanette Kellen ?
C'est ça. À à ses côtés, il y a la
patronne de la Fed, la Fédérale réserve
américaine de l'époque
de l'époque, elle a changé depuis et euh
et Larry est là au volant et derrière il
y a une il y a une bande de jeunes qui
crient, qui boivent des coups, qui euh
qui qui font la fête et cetera et Larry
accélère, il est hilar au truc et tout
et Jeanette lui dit "Mais Larry, calme
le jeu, on va se planter et tout." Et
lui dit "On en a rien à [__] on
fonce, on fonce." Et à un moment donné,
il va qu'est-ce qui va se passer
fatalement ? Donc il regarde la il
regarde la reifing en posant la question
et tu as la reifing qui est complètement
décomposé quoi. Et il dit le bus va
faire une embartée, il va tomber et il
va se fracasser sur un Black Rock, un un
rochet noir.
Il est pas décomposé hein. La seule
chose qui à mon sens indique qu'il a été
surpris, c'est un haussement de sourcil
et inclement. Et ensuite juste après, il
a un flegme tout à fait British. C'est
qu'il bouge pas.
Ouais, c'est ça. Mais tu sens quand même
quand tu connais le personnage qu'il est
qu'il est il est emmerdé par ça.
D'ailleurs, le c'est c'est donc ça ça
m'a donné envie. Donc j'ai appelé un de
mes mes mon ami un ami éditeur qui
s'appelle Florent Masso et j'ai dit à
Florent écoute ce film là plus le fait
que Larryf vienne à Paris rencontrer
Macron assez souvent il faut il faut
prendre les droits de d'un livre. Il y a
une journaliste allemande qui travaille
à Wall Street euh qui a écrit un livre
euh sur Black Rock, il faut il faut
prendre les droits, le faire traduire.
Euh si tu veux, je te ferai la préface.
Et donc j'ai participé à je participe à
à l'édition du livre. Et euh donc le le
Florent prend les droits, j'écris ma
préface, je me tape la lecture du
bouquin qui fait 400 pages qui est une
sorte de d'enquête assez fouillée, assez
académique mais qui m'apprend vraiment
des choses sur sur Larif et sur Black
Rock. Et puis euh l'avocate lit ma
préface, enfin elle fait 30 pages, enfin
25 pages la préface et euh et et tout va
bien. Et un jour Florent m'appelle et il
était super emmerdé, il me dit "Écoute,
il y a un problème avec ta préface,
l'éditeur allemand et et
n'en veut pas."
Et là, je tombe de truc, je dis "Ah bon
?" Et puis euh on discute un peu et ma
première action est de lui dire "Bon bah
écoute, c'est pas grave, j'ai un peu les
boules mais voilà. C'est qu'une préface,
j'aurais passé une semaine à bosser.
Pourquoi il en veut pas ?
Alors, il en veut pas. Il y a il y a
deux explications. Soit c'est press.
Sais rien.
Je j'en j'en sais rien. Mais mais
Florent pense ça. Il pense que la
journaliste travaillant à Wall Street,
côtoyant en permanence ces gens-là, on
lui elle travaille dans un journal
allemand sérieux et cetera. On lui fait
comprendre que s'associer avec un un
type comme moi, c'est peut-être pas la
meilleure des des idées. J'ai fait
Clearstream avant, je suis pas un
journaliste académique. Enfin, je je
sais pas, toujours est-il que que ma
préface est censurée. Et ma préface
pas censurée, elle est juste refusée.
Elle est refusée mais ça ressemble à une
censure puisque elle était ton
interprétation.
C'est pas que la mienne. C'est pas que
la mienne. À un moment, tu écris une
préface, tout le monde est d'accord, il
y a pas de problème de diffamation. Euh,
elle tient la route. Je je j'essaie de
donner mon explication de qui est Laarif
et de pourquoi. C'est très très
important de s'intéresser à Black Rock.
Et puis après, si tu veux, il y a un
échange de courrier, il y a des il y a
Florent fait vraiment le maximum pour
que la préface passe et puis les autres
refusent. Mais tu sens qu'il y a de
l'embarras et puis après il y a des il y
a des choses que les les gens se disent
en off quoi. Et en off on on récupère
des infos qui font que ils avaient peur
des procès de Black Rock, ils avaient
peur de d'être emmerdés sur ce truc
alors qu'il y avait encore une fois ça
avait été relu par deux avocats. Donc il
y avait pas de problème de diffamation.
J'ai une relative expérience mais si
j'en je sais puisque j'ai euh j'ai quand
même l'expérience des procès en
diffamation et franchement j'ai envie de
tout en ce moment que de j'ai pas envie
d'avoir de nouveaux procès. Donc je fais
gaffe même si j'écris d'ailleurs la
préface est dans les annexes du livre.
Euh les gens qui liront le livre
pourront se faire le leur opinion.
Toujours est-il que les livres c'est
comme ça, il c'est toujours une
dynamique, une colère où il y a quelque
chose. Donc là, il se passe 3 4 jours.
Moi, j'ai un peu les boules mais je dis
rien. Euh je dis à Florent : "Écoute,
lui, il avait déjà investi, il avait
payé la traduction, il avait acheté les
droits du livre et tout. Donc c'est pas
non plus un éditeur, c'est pas c'est pas
Galimar quoi. C'est c'est un un bon
éditeur mais il a pas de fond propre
énorme et cetera. Et puis donc moi, je
le convains de de pas s'énerver et de
publier le le le bouquin euh qui va
sortir d'ailleurs parce que l'histoire
est assez belle. le bouquin finalement
sorti sortira dans 3 semaines à peu
près. Et et un matin, on on je me
réveille en me disant "Putain, je peux
pas laisser passer ça quoi. Je peux pas
pourquoi cette préface est censurée
puisque euh et donc je je dis à Florent
euh écoute, j'ai réfléchi euh je pense
que soit je fais un grand papier parce
qu'il y a plusieurs canards qui
m'avaient commandé des papiers mais dès
le départ j'avais plutôt envie d'écrire
un petit bouquin quoi et je me dis je
vais je vais je vais m'y mettre quoi et
je vais écrire sur Black Rock parce que
en même temps c'est pas uniquement un
livre sur Black Rock que je commence
c'est plus un livre de réflexion sur la
finance et tout ce que tout ce que
j'avais accumulé comme info, comme
sensation sur Clearstream je commençais
à le retrouver à à ce ce moment-là. Donc
c'est cet été, ça c'est la fin du mois
de juillet, je commence à me mettre dans
dans l'idée d'écrire le livre et il se
passe un truc, c'est que je me casse je
me casse le pied en jouant avec mon mon
chien. Je me pète le le pied, ça fait
très mal et tu peux plus poser le pied
au sol donc tu es un peu immobile. Donc
j'ai gardé, tu sais, un peu comme dans
fenêtre sur cours avec James Stewart,
j'ai gardé mon pied
avec une canne et tout ça et et donc je
n'avais plus qu'une chose à faire. Donc
j'étais assez désagrable pour mon
entourage, mais c'était écrire. Donc je
n'ai cessé d'écrire entre le le disons
le le le 31 juillet et le le le 7 ou le
8 septembre, j'ai passé 6 semaines en
gros à ne faire que ça. Et
je tu sais quand tu écris tu tu démarres
un premier chapitre. Enfin moi c'est pas
un bouquin financier que je fais, c'est
un bouquin très personnel. C'est pour ça
que j'ai appelé çaarri et moi parce que
il est un peu plus âgé que moi. Je fais
un parallèle entre sa vie et la mienne.
Et ça me permet aussi de faire une
introspection sur moi-même, sur pourquoi
c'est important d'écrire là-dessus.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que de faire du
journalisme aujourd'hui ? Euh pourquoi
quand je raconte cette cette scène chez
mon père où je d avec lui ou que tout
est black rock en quelque sorte, je dis
mais qu'il y a derrière ? Quelles sont
les intentions de ces types ? Pourquoi
il est il est venu aussi souvent en
France ? Je découvre par exemple que le
type il passe pour un parce que il veut
investir dans la finance verte comme le
font tous ces gros tous ces gros ces
gros milliardaires et tu te rends compte
que il a acheté trois Golfstam c'est les
les avions c'est comme les Humer de
l'air quoi, tu vois c'est les avions qui
polluent le plus et avec ces trois
avions il est venu h fois en France pour
faire du lobbying et cetera donc je tire
plein de fils et ça je le sais parce que
j'ai des copains aiguères du ciel qui je
les remercie d'ailleurs qui m'ont envoyé
les plans de vol de ces de c qui des
fois ils viennent en France sous des
faux noms, tu vois. Enfin, il y a il y a
il y a un de leurs avions qui est
inscrit euh pas au nom de au nom de
Black Rock mais d'une autre société
écran. Enfin,
on en profite, je suis désolé de te
couper, on en profite pour dire merci à
nos amis de la communauté qui spotent
les avions.
Ouais.
Qui sont en train de nous faire remonter
de l'information sur ce qui se passe
audessus de la Turquie, a-udessus de
l'Arménie et au-dessus de de certains
pays là-bas parce qu'il y a des avions
qui qui décollent et puis hop, ils
disparaissent. Hm. Ah oui,
les les transpondeurs, on les voit plus.
Ah oui, d'accord. Je
Donc du type avion de renseignement,
c'est très rigolo mais bon, je te laisse
continuer, désolé. Merci.
Non non, mais après on peut parler des
bombardiers qui sont en ce moment des
bombardiers américains avec leur
missiles
ou russes qui s'amusent à aller chez
nous.
Voilà, il y a un très bon papier dans
les crises que j'ai lu ce matin
là-dessus. Et et pareil, c'est tu vois,
je on parle de ça, on fait une
parenthèse, mais c'est des informations
avec ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
effectivement euh le terrorisme, le
Covid et cetera, mais des informations
cruciales comme celle-là de de de
l'aviation américaine de guerre qui
s'installe en Angleterre, la guerre
froide qui est terminée avec la Russie
et cetera, c'est des infos qui passent
non mais c'est pas terminé mais au
contraire ça passe sous les radars quoi.
Et donc c'est très important que des
sites comme le tien ou les nôtres alors
évidemment après on c'est des infos qui
deviennent tellement originales mais qui
sont quand même très factuel tu vois. Il
y a, je crois qu'il y a une, enfin, il
faut relire les crises, mais il y a une
quarantaine de bombardiers américains
qui sont équipés de huit missiles
sol air, des truc de fou, qui sont
stationnés en Angleterre, prêt à
intervenir, qui font des des tu sens
qu'il y a que il y a un combat de muscle
entre Poutine et et les États-Unis en
si c'est des missiles dans les avions,
c'est pas des solaires. Moi c'est euh
pardon excuse-moi, je je C'est des airul
évidemment encore que l'avion au sol il
peut enfin je sais pas non je déconne.
Euh non mais voilà écoute donc ce que je
voulais lar
ouais la Larry ce qui s'est passé c cet
été. J'ai beaucoup pensé à à Cavana
parce que j'ai, tu sais, ben j'étais
venu la dernière fois pour parler de lui
et de et de de Charlie et de de de tout
ça. Et Cavana dans le le documentaire,
dans l'entretien que je fais avec lui,
il me dit euh euh tu sais la nuit euh
quand je suis sous mon sous mon rayon de
lumière et et quand quand j'écris, il y
a rien de plus beau, quoi. Et quand
tuattrapes le tagada,
plus rien peut t'arrêter quoi. Et ça
faisait très longtemps que je je je
n'avais pas attrapé le Tagada, quoi.
C'est-à-dire ce moment où tu écris et
que tout est tu as comme un un tout
s'aligne devant toi et les mots arrivent
tout seul. et même pour un bouquin aussi
compliqué que que Larry et moi qui
apparemment est compliqué. J'ai j'essaie
de le rendre simple et et et de et de
raconter cette histoire qui m'a qui me
mène assez loin d'ailleurs. Il y a une
trentaine de chapitres à la fin je
réfléchis aux banques centrales de
comment c'est possible et cetera et je
suis toujours habité par la par la même
question depuis depuis 20 ans
d'ailleurs. C'est c'est comment des pays
aussi riches que les nôtres produisent
autant de pauvreté ? Et l'explication,
est elle est en partie dans le livre
aujourd'hui. Il faut faire très
attention à Black Rock, à la manière
dont dont cette République en marche et
ce ce gouvernement hyper libéral
est influencé par des des types comme la
Rifing qui ont quand même table ouverte
à l'Élysée, quoi. C'est quand même donc
et et tu vois qu'ils s'en prennent ils
s'en prennent à tous. Larifing, c'est un
type, il y a il y a très peu d'interview
de lui où il se lâche, mais c'est quand
même le pire des libertariens. C'est le
type qui te dit "Mais un homme ne peut
s'épanouir que par le travail. Euh lui,
il est pour la retraite à 75 ans si on
le laisse faire, tu vois." Et donc
voilà, c'est euh les dès que tu parles
de de l'État, ça le c'est un gros mot
pour lui. Service public, ça veut rien
dire.
Il a le droit d'avoir ce point de
vue-là.
Bah, je dis pas qu'il a pas le droit,
mais moi j'ai le droit d'écrire sur lui
et j'ai le droit de d'essayer de de
décrypter ce mécanisme là et surtout de
m'interroger sur quel est le but d'un
type comme ça quoi. Pourquoi il
continue, il a 68 ans ? Pourquoi il il
continue à faire ce qu'il fait, à faire
autant de dégâts ? Parce qu'il fait des
dégâts. Je raconte plein d'histoires
dans le film.
Il fait aussi Il fait peut-être aussi
des choses positives. Non,
il investit dans le green.
Non, il fait rien de positif. il
s'occupe des retraites,
il investit pas dans le green. Il il il
est très d'ailleurs, c'est pour ça qu'il
y a eu extinction rébellion qui ont fait
cette truc, c'est qu'il investi beaucoup
sur le pétrole, les mines de charbon et
cetera. Il gagne beaucoup d'argent grâce
à ça quoi. Et franchement, c'est une
c'est une une plaie pour un État nation
comme le nôtre que d'accepter que des
types comme Larryf viennent aussi
souvent en France que des types comme
Jean-François Cyrelli qui est son homme
lige ici. Cyrelli, c'est sans doute le
plus le patron le plus libéral. euh qui
qui soit quoi son il a mais est-ce que
je dis le contraire ? Je dis pas mais je
dis que c'est un pour moi c'est c'est ça
fait de sérieux dégâts
à à tous les niveaux quoi. Parce que aux
États-Unis avant Rigan, ça se passait
plutôt bien. Les les les pensionnés
américains, ils avaient leurs actions.
Il y avait une sorte d'équilibre qui
était trouvé quoi. Et Rigan a a comment
dire les les les entreprises ont délégué
à leur personnel la possibilité de de
placer leur retraite en bourse. Ça a été
le début de la fin
des régulations.
Ouais, d'accord. Mais mais c'est c'est
ça que ça veut dire. Il y a eu 30 % de
pauvreté en plus. Enfin, il y a des
stades qui existent là-dessus. Et
aujourd'hui,
ils nous ils importent ce modèle là.
Ici, c'est alors ils disent "Non, on
fait pas la retraite par capitalisation,
mais c'est faux. Quand tu étudies la
réforme sur les retraites, tu vois bien
que les les gros les gros salaires ne ne
au-dessus de 10000 € par mois sont plus
solidaires des autres et que et que
c'est pour ça que Black Rock est là pour
pour aspirer cette cette cet argent-là
qui petit à petit à petit pardon détruit
tout ce tout ce que sont nos services
publics. Si l'hôpital est dans cette
galère aujourd'hui, c'est parce qu'il y
a ses fonds de pension, c'est parce
qu'il y a ces fonds d'investissement qui
qui l'argent au lieu d'être investi dans
les dans les services publics, bah elle
est investie en bourse et puis il se
passe ses bulles et c'est à un moment
donné quand la bulle explose, c'est un
peu l'effet dominaux. C'est ce qui
risque de nous arriver avec Black Rock.
Tu tu as jamais discuté avec je vais
dire ces gens-là entre guillemets de du
moins
cette upper classe. Est-ce que tu as
déjà discuter à bâton rompu avec un un
grand directeur de banque internationale
? Est-ce que
Bien sûr ça mé
mais à bâton rompu, c'est autour d'un
verre avec un un cigare et un whisky et
là on on discute.
Non pas autour d'un verre avec un cigare
whisky mais je déjà discuté avec des
traders. J'ai enfin oui, je
Non mais les traders c'est c'est pas ça
le trader. Le trader à mon sens n'est
qu'un tout petit maillon euh euh qui qui
qui n'est pas grand-chose en fait dans
ce système là. Mais le tu as jamais
discuté avec le patron patron des
traders ? Non, mais j'ai déjà discuté
avec des des gros banquiers dont un
certains m'ont aidé d'ailleurs sur
Clairstream parce que c certains
banquiers de droite enfin je veux dire
ou même même de gauche parce qu' il y en
a certains qui qui sont étiquetés à
gauche sont eux-mêmes inquiets de de la
place que peut prendre la la finance
noire dans dans l'économie quoi. Il il y
a des banquiers qui peuvent qui peuvent
expliquer à quel point les les paradis
fiscaux sont une plie, à quel point
l'évasion fiscale est une plie. Donc ça
c'est des conversations que j'ai pu
avoir avec eux
et ils t'ont jamais sur le fil de ces
conversations, ils t'ont jamais susuré à
l'oreille. Voilà ce qui nous agace dans
dans ces gouvernements super encadrés,
c'est le nivellement par le bas. Tu as
jamais entendu cette phrase là ?
Si, je ben je vois ce que tu veux dire.
Mais mais bon, ils ont ils ont un
discours rationalisant par rapport à ça
quoi. Ils sont bien obligés de justifier
la ce qu'ils sont en train de faire.
Donc moi, j'ai pas de mensuétude à à
leur égard. J'ai pas de haine non plus.
Mais mais c'est des discours qui ne
m'émuent à aucun moment, quoi.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire le
nivellement par le bas pour eux à ton
avis ?
Euh ben c'est-à-dire que eux sont je
pense qu'ils ont une une vision de la la
société qui est très élitiste et donc
euh la plupart de ces gens-là ont
intégré l'idée que euh l'idée qu'un
groupe qui est un groupe de gens très
intelligents doit dominer
la plebe et que ça
c'est ton interprétation.
Oui, c'est mon que tu me demandes. Je te
réponds.
Je peux mettre une petite nuance ?
Vas-y, je t'en prie. Et euh ce petit
groupe peut-être pense que bah pour eux,
il faut se sortir les doigts du cul,
aller bosser, aller bosser, aller
bosser, aller bosser jusqu'à 75 ans et
que c'est la seule chose qui va nous
sauver. C'est ça
un peu. H
Je te laisse continuer.
Non, non, mais je je pas grand-chose
d'autre à dire parce que là, on rentre
sur le sur le terrain politique et on
voit bien en ce moment comment
politique c'est très politique
l'investissement.
Bien sûr, mais et et mais c'est là où le
où le les investissements boursiers
tuent l'économie à un moment. C'estàd
que la la bourse est devenue c'est pour
ça que la la prémonition de Michael
Burry est importante. C'est-à-dire que
normalement, si tu veux, tu tu discutes
avec les tu tu vois comment fonctionnait
la bourse avant l'arrivée des traders,
avant l'arrivée des robots et cetera. Il
y avait une une c'est c'està-dire un
moment dans le bouquin d'ailleurs, il y
a il y a eu une enquête qui a été
ouverte à à New York contre contre la
Rifing qui est par un procureur et le
procureur dit le rêve de tout américain
c'était d'avoir sa maison et ses
actions. On est dans les années dans les
années 60 quoi 50 60 jusqu'au milieu des
années 70 on va dire. Le type, il avait
ses actions en bourse et il investissait
en bourse parce qu'il investissait dans
l'économie, parce qu'il se disait voilà,
je vais [__] 10000 dollars et ça va
aider à à à construire des usines, à
faire que et moi ça va me rapporter de
l'argent et cetera. Aujourd'hui, c'est
plus du tout ça. Je veux dire, le type
qui investit en bourse, c'est pour se
faire le maximum de cash, sans le
minimum de temps. Et il y a plus de de
lien entre l'économie et
l'investissement boursier. C'est
d'ailleurs un des drames totals de de de
nos sociétés, le libéralisme, c'est ça
quand même, c'est cette espèce de de de
d'adoration et de dévoration boursière,
quoi. Et la la bourse à un moment donné
va évidemment péter. Moi, je suis pas
boursicoteur et et et fatalement les
types qui vont morfler en en bourse, ce
sont les boursicoteurs. C'est-à-dire
c'est qui quelle est la cible de de de
ces des gens comme la ref ? Bah c'est
les petits épargnants, les petits ou
même les gros ou les moyens puisque
enfin faudrait qu'on situe une échelle
mais en dessous de 100000 € enfin tu es
un petit un petit épargnant enfin moyen
épargnant on va dire
à partir de 10000 100 millions d'euros
on a un conseil spécif
Black Rock tu es tu es très privilégié
quoi. Mais autrement Black Rock pourquoi
ça marche aussi Black Rock c'est parce
que si tu veux acheter des ETF donc
aller en bourse tu ça coûte ça te coûte
pas grand-chose tu passes pas par un
intermédiaire financier et cetera quoi.
Il faut aussi dire que Black Rock a
divisé les coûts pour rentrer en bourse.
Oui. Bah oui, ils ont divisé mais c'est
là où ils ont leurs ETF leurs ETF sont
quand même une une à terme ça peut pas
continuer à fonctionner quoi. C'est
c'est c'est des indices quoi qui je te
dis c'est indifférencié. Donc les
indices boursiers ne veulent plus rien
dire à cause des ETF.
Est-ce que ça te fait peur tout ça ? Ça
me fait assez peur. Oui, parce que je
pense que la métaphore de Carl Ikan dont
je parlais tout à l'heure est assez
juste. C'est-à-dire qu'on a donné les
clés du camion à un type comme Larifing
et j'ai aucune confiance en Larifing.
C'est-à-dire que il a créé un monstre
qui l'a dépassé. Black Rock, c'est un
monstre qui a des tentacules partout
mais partout. C'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui les loyers grimpent à Berlin
parce que la Rifing a investi dans
l'immobilier.
Euh quand tu tu bois un verre de une
bouteille de Bordeaux, Larifing est le
plus grand conseilleur d'investissement
dans les vignobles français. Euh tout ce
qui est industrie automobile,
c'est bien pour les vignobes français
d'avoir du cash.
Ouais, c'est c'est Non, je pense pas que
ce soit bien. Enfin, je sais pas. Moi du
diable encore.
Non, mais moi je suis je suis de mon tu
connais un documentaire qui s'appelle
Mondovino. Voilà quoi. Enfin, je veux
dire le pinard c'est ça quoi. C'est
quand même un peu l'artisanat. Enfin, il
y a des il y a des viticulteurs qui font
très bien leur boulot, mais c'est pas
Bernard Arnaud qui rachète le le je sais
plus que comment s'appelle sans cru.
On passe d'ailleurs le bonjour à tous
les vignerons qui font de la biodynamie.
Voilà. Hm hm.
E euh autre question euh quand euh
l'argent des retraites des Français est
poussé vers un un retraite par
capitalisation,
est-ce que ça expose Je me je me fais un
peu candide, est-ce que ça expose les
Français à des aléas sur leur retraite ?
Bah forcément, mais ça c'est caché.
C'est c'est d'ailleurs c'est la reifing
va jamais t'expliquer ça. C'est-à-dire
que ça veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire que
tu confies ton argent
à Black Rock et à Larif et ils en font
ce qu'ils veulent.
Quand sign quand tu signes ton contrat,
il y a bien marqué, vous vous exposez
quand même à un risque.
Bah justement, mais c'est c'est tout
tout tout tout le problème. C'est-à-dire
que en gros, tu dois
le Black Rock est devenu tellement
important que tu as vu Black Rock
conseille la BCE.
Blackrooc
a sauvé l'économie américaine. Ils ont
prêté 8000 milliards, enfin ils ont
cautionné 8 milliards d'emprunt à la Fed
au moment de la crise du Covid. Il y a
eu un ça a fait la une des échos. Enfin,
je veux dire, ils sont omni
omnipuissants partout quoi. Et donc tu
te dis toi la Rifing qui vient vendre,
on est trop gros pour tomber donc
filez-nous votre argent. Vous gagnerez
toujours plus que votre sur votre [__]
de livret d'épargne où vous perdez de
l'argent en ce moment. Je crois qu'il
est il est côté à 0,75 et l'inflation
est à 1 2. Donc voilà et lui il te
garantit toujours un un peu plus que ça.
Donc tu te dis toi tu es retraité, tu te
dis bon ben je vais [__] mes œufs dans
ce panierlà. Mais c'est un énorme risque
parce qu'à un moment donné tout ça aussi
peut s'effondrer. Et si Black Rock
s'effondre euh euh tu t'en parlais tout
à l'heure, c'estàd que si au même moment
tout le monde veut vendre ses ETF, le
truc meurt. Mais c'est une vue de
l'esprit, ça peut pas se passer comme
ça. Mais mais par contre Black Rock si
tu veux est devenu tellement
tellement présent et tellement puissant
y compris auprès des des banques
centrales qu'il y a pas de décision de
des banquiers centraux qui se prennent
ou même au niveau de la BCE sans que la
Rifing soit soit au courant ou ses
services soient au courant et et et
donne son avis, il y a une
interpénétration. Bah c'est normal, oui
et non parce que une banque centrale
devrait être complètement indépendante
mais ça n'est absolument pas le cas. Je
vais te poser une question euh euh un
peu piquante. Est-ce que c'est pas une
nouvelle croisade de Denis Robert,
journaliste de gauche, qui veut se faire
la finance ?
Non, parce que là là le le fait que je
sois de gauche ou pas de gauche, ça ça a
pas de sens. C'est-à-dire c'est et puis
c'est pas une croisade non plus. C'est
un type qui se casse le pied fin juillet
et qui se met à écrire sur Black Rock
parce que il se dit "Qu'est-ce que je
comprends rien à tout ça, il faut que il
faut que je réussisse à comprendre." Et
je découvre des choses, je raconte un
truc, c'est un papier que je lis. Alors,
je me suis beaucoup servi de Google Trad
parce que mon anglais est quand même est
quand même il est pas balbuciant mais
mais pour pour lire des fois en anglais,
je passe par des traducteurs et cetera.
J'ai lu un article absolument
passionnant dans le dans le Financial
Times qui expliquait que les que les ETF
c'était comme les canaris dans les mines
de charbon. Tu sais, tu les les mineurs
au siècle dernier, ils mettaient des
petits oiseaux et on oublie que c'est
quand l'oiseau s'arrête de chanter, que
le gaz arrive, l'oiseau meurt et ça
pète. C'est le coup de grisou quoi. Et
et les les le papier expliquait assez
bien que justement le quand tu vois que
sur les marchés financiers, les ETF
commencent à s'échanger avec frénésie,
c'est le moment où où le le craque
boursier peut arriver. Ça s'est passé,
ça s'est passé au moment du Covid. Euh
euh et là les banques centrales sont
intervenues pour éviter la catastrophe.
Donc ils peuvent le faire mais la
planche habillée peut marcher mais elle
peut pas marcher éternellement quoi. En
ce moment, on a l'impression que
l'argent arrive de mars mais à un moment
donné tout se paye quoi.
Tout se paye dans quel sens ?
Bah tout se paye dans le sens d'un
effondrement de de de des économies et
de et des industries, ce qu'on est en
train de vivre en ce moment. Et
d'ailleurs à comment euh à en Suisse à à
Davos là, ils ont cette année, j'ai
découvert un truc, moi je je connaissais
pas, c'est le grand reset. Tu as entendu
parler de ça ? Donc c'est à un moment
donné ces types c'est
bonjour Christine.
Ouais. On ont imaginé Christine la
garde, tu veux dire ? Ils ont imaginé
que ça allait être tellement la Qatar
qu'ils allaient remettre les compteurs à
zéro. Mais les compteurs à zéro pour
eux, pas pour pas pour les gens parce
que du jour au lendemain quand tu te
retrouves avec zéro sur ton ton compte
pu de salaire,
pas zéro, pas zéro, c'est une une
dévaluation de ce qu'il y a sur ton
compte de 30 %.
Ouais, enfin je dis zéro, enfin aller
jusque là. Le le le le grand reset à un
moment, c'est c'est on remet les
compteurs à zéro, il y a plus de dette,
il y a plus donc voilà, moi je Donc ils
ont imaginé aussi ces scénarios
catastrophes si tu veux. Donc en ce
moment entre les attentats et et le
Covid, on on oublie la planète
financière, mais à un moment, elle va se
réveiller, quoi. C'est comme un volcan
qui gronde.
Je vais te poser une question pour le
novice qui souhaiterait euh euh se
renseigner sur les paradis fiscaux,
comprendre il faut qu'il commence par
quoi ? Est-ce que tu as des livres, des
des pistes à conseiller ? Imagine-toi
dans dans nos auditeurs, dans nos
podcasters euh tu leur dirais voilà si
tu veux comprendre ce qui se passe
commence par ça puis après tu com tu
t'enchaînes sur ça, tu leur conseilles
quoi ?
Écoute-moi, sur le la question des
paradis fiscaux, je m'y suis intéressé
quand j'étais à Libération encore. À
l'époque, personne s'y intéressait et
puis j'ai avancé je crois qu'il y a un
livre qui a je pas
il y a mon bouquin révélation quoi,
enfin la boîte noire qui était de livres
où j'ai justement j'ai une approche qui
est pas celle d'un journaliste
financier, donc qui qui permet de de
comprendre ça. Et moi je le je ça c'est
autrement je je dirais de lire Zucman.
Gabriel Zucman
tous ces bouquins expliquent assez bien
aujourd'hui son idée de faire un
cadastre mondial. Il y a beaucoup de
gens qui réfléchissent à tout ça. Il y a
euh et alors c'est pas des livres mais
les enquêtes de Maxime Ren qu'on a sorti
au médias sont absolument passionnantes
pour ça. et tu vois tu vois à quel point
là la dernière qui qui sort qui aurait
dû sortir chez nous sur l'actalis tu
vois que toutes les grosses sociétés
française qui et la pire c'est l'enquête
sur les épades qu'il avait faite où tu
vois que que en pleine période de Covid
les les ÉPAD privées envoient de
l'argent sur les paradis fiscaux donc ça
continue ou que BFM il a sorti un truc
sur BFM où tu vois que la régie
publicitaire de BFM
passe par des sociétés écran et marche
dans les paradis fiscaux actuell
Actuellement, je suis en train moi de
enfin c'est surtout Yannick qui qui
travaille mais je vais le rejoindre
bientôt au montage. On a on a lancé une
grande souscription sur le un film qui
s'appelle la très grande évasion et on
on essaie d'expliquer à quel point la
fiscalité est une est une matière très
intéressante et très importante et que
et qu'il se passe des choses en coulisse
qui sont complètement inavouables.
On a une question internet.
D'après Marianne, Larryf a ses entrées à
l'Élysée et aurait influencé des
réformes encadrant le travail. Qu'en
pense de Nis ?
Bah non, mais bien sûr, mais ça c'est
avec Cyrélie. Enfin, il est c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure. Donc il a il a
l'oreille de de de Macron. C'estàd que
on a une image où Emmanuel Macron lui
tape sur l'épaule. euh il les a reçus à
l'Élysée, pas que lui, mais il les a
reçu à à à plusieurs reprises, quoi.
Donc euh euh pour Emmanuel Macron, tout
ce qui est private equity, tout ce qui
est investissement des grosses banques
américaines, c'est très important pour
la France quoi. Et c'est capital Louisa
au bordur quoi. Il y a le capital sans
frontière quoi. Donc et les États sont
mangés par ça et la BCE est mangée par
par l'influence de ces gens-là. On l'a
bien vu récemment puisque euh l'Europe a
choisi euh euh Black Rock comme
conseiller pour tout ce qui est
investissement vert et cetera, quoi. Il
y a voilà, c'est
Autre question Internet. Euh qu'est-ce
qui après tous ces problèmes
Clearstream, le média, Black Rock le
maintient encore en forme ? Quelle est
sa motivation pour tenir ?
Mais moi, moi je suis euh bon là sur le
média, ça a été je m'y attendais pas du
tout. Je m'attendais pas à ce qui
arrivait. C'est peut-être ma naïveté,
mais ce qui fait ma force, c'est sans
doute cette naïveté. C'est-à-dire moi,
je la vie est la
pour moi la vie, c'est beaucoup
l'écriture. Donc donc chaque fois que je
vis des choses délicates, je me dis que
c'est de la littérature. Je me dis je
vais en faire quelque chose. Et ce qui
me ce qui me motive le plus, c'est
d'aller où où où personne ne va quoi.
C'est-à-dire j'allais pas faire 50 fois
le même livre et cetera. Là, Black Rock,
j'avais l'impression que j'avais
vraiment quelque chose à dire. Euh là,
je je me trouve pas très bon là dans
dans l'interview qu'on fait ensemble
parce que je je réponds à tes à tes
questions, mais quand j'étais dans mon
livre, j'étais dans une sorte de de
j'étais complètement habitée par mon
sujet.
Toujours toujours critique envers
toi-même, mais tu es toujours pas ça
mais et et là, ça fait ça fait un mois
que que j'ai pu parler de Black Rock si
tu veux. tu m'aurais interviewé il y a
un mois, j'aurais été une vraie fusée.
Là, je je me souviens plus des enfin je
si je me je je
sais pourquoi je l'ai écrit, quoi. Et je
pense qu'à la fin du livre, d'ailleurs à
la fin du livre, on a eu l'idée de de
parce que parce que Black Rock est un
est un sujet euh d'importance,
c'est ça qui te motive.
Ouais. de faire une lettre.
Ça fait tenir.
De quoi ? C'est ça qui te fait tenir.
Mais moi, j'ai pas un rapport à la vie
qui m'oblige à tenir. Si tu veux, j'ai
un rapport à la vie beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus cool que ça, quoi. Mais ce
qui me fait toujours enquêter, c'est euh
c'est une sorte de nécessité de de
témoigner, quoi. Enfin, je veux dire,
j'ai gardé la même quand quand
j'écrivais à Libération il y a 30 ans,
j'étais motivé par les mêmes choses
qu'aujourd'hui. C'est-à-dire que je
regarde, je suis surtout édifié par
alors je veux pas donner de leçons à mes
confrères journalistes, mais
c'est tellement mauvais euh BFM, ITL,
LCI, enfin je vais encore me prendre
plein la gueule mais c'est tellement
mauvais. Euh il y a tellement peu
d'informations, c'est tellement une
sorte de brassage permanent, les types
se renvoient des ascenseurs, des balles,
c'est des côteries et cetera, que c'est
presque facile de faire du journalisme à
côté de ces ces ces gens-là. Donc donc
je me il y a des sujets comme ça qui me
semblent vraiment important et
d'ailleurs je pense que je je pense que
le livre enfin comme tous les livres que
j'écrit j'ai j'ai retrouvé avec Larry et
moi un peu l'énergie que j'avais dans
pendant les affaires les affaires
continues. Tu sais pendant les affaires
les affaires continues qui était mon
premier succès de librairie on va dire
les les médias pendant 3 mois en ont pas
parlé quoi. Et il y a eu des papiers
parce que le bouquin a commencé à
marcher et cetera. Là le bouquin est
sorti ce matin euh par la communaut par
Facebook j'ai mis un truc et tout. Il y
a il y a eu 600 ou 700 achats en en
quelques heures. Donc j'imagine que le
bouche oreille va fonctionner grâce au
livre et malgré le Covid, malgré la
fermeture des librairies. C'est-à-dire
que un livre, pourquoi on l'écrit ?
C'est moi je l'écris pas pour euh
franchement j'écris ça parce que il y a
une sorte de motivation ultime qui me
dit [__] il faut il faut que j'y
aille. Pourquoi je passe ? J'aurais pu
aller me bronzer
à la plage ou faire des tas de choses.
D'ailleurs, je me suis je suis assez dur
à vivre pour mon entourage. Mais
pourquoi je m'enferme pendant bon, je me
suis pété le pied, mais pourquoi je
m'enferme pendant 6 semaines ? je passe
pas de vacances et tout parce que je
suis complètement habité par l'idée que
c'est une nécessité absolue d'écrire
là-dessus et comme disait Cavana, bon là
il se trouve que j'écris sur la finance
mais j'écrirai sans doute sur autre
chose après. C'est-à-dire que le
problème que j'ai eu avec le le média
c'est que pendant 18 mois j'ai pas pu
écrire. Je je croyais que j'aurais le
temps d'écrire, de faire des choses à
côté. J'ai pas pu. Ça occupé
complètement ma vie. J'ai fait que ça
euh à travailler 60 heures par semaine,
à m'investir à fond dans le truc et
c'est pour ça que là j'ai retrouver un
peu ce plaisir et et et mais il fallait
que le sujet me me
soit d'importance quoi. Et je pense
qu'il l'
et c'est c'est c'est totalement égoïste
ou c'est pour l'intérêt général ? C'est
les c'est les deux mon capitaine.
C'est-à-dire que je prends du plaisir à
le faire parce que c'est pour c'est pour
l'intérêt général évidemment. C'est tu
écris des livres comme ça, c'est pour
que les gens s'en emparent, on
discutent, ça suscite des débats et
cetera. C'est tellement scandaleux ce
qu'il nous ont fait euh euh je parle
même pas des gilets jaunes mais sur les
retraites. Enfin, tout toute cette
manière dont dont on a capté euh euh cet
argent-là, tout le discours qui a été
créé autour, euh le fait qu'on était
soi-disant faillite, le le violon de de
tous ces chentres qui qu'on voit passer
partout à la télé qui sont là, oh là là,
c'est grave, on narrivera jamais à
financer les retraites et cetera. C'est
des conneries. C'est-à-dire que les
retraites, on pouvait très bien les Il y
avait il y a pas de problème de
financement des retraites. Il manque
quoi ? Il manque 10 12 milliards, c'est
rien.
Alors, ils ont inventé euh ils invent
cette c'est un storytelling permanent,
quoi.
Question question internet. Que
pensent-il de la greffe de la fin
initiée par le rapporteur du budget
européen Pierre Larouto, pour taxer les
transactions financières ? Peut-on
encore changer l'Europe ?
Je savais pas qu'il avait démarré une
grève de la fin. Je je il m'a envoyé son
dernier livre. Évidemment qu'on on
pourrait taxer les transactions
financières. Ça fait des années que
c'est un serpent de mer, quoi. Euh mais
je pense que l'Europe est dans un tel
État aujourd'hui. Moi, je suis très
proeuropéen, mais euh que je suis
souverainiste par endroit et proeuropéen
par d'autres. J'ai une lecture assez
différente de de je me retrouve pas du
tout dans les dans
chez Michel Onfray par exemple et
cetera. Tout ce qui tout c cette ce
repli. Je pense je pense que par
exemple, il faut créer une Europe
judiciaire.
Absolument. C'està-dire que c'est le
seul moyen de lutter.
C'est pas déjà le cas. Non, c'est pas le
cas du tout. C'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui tu tu veux tu lances une
commission gatoire en France, ça c'est
l'appel de Genève que j'avais fait il y
a 20 ans,
a toujours pas été réalisé quoi. Mais
par contre, il faut sans doute qu'il y
ait du souverainisme économique par
endroit. Enfin, il y a des c'est un
vaste sujet que je vais je vais pas
forcément aborder ici avec vous.
Non, mais je je le l'Europe, moi je suis
profondément européen, mais l'État dans
lequel elle est, enfin depuis Junker,
c'est une catastrophe quoi. Donc donc
voilà. Enfin, je veux dire
autre question internet. Comment
résoudre les problèmes de conflit
d'intérêt, corruption de nos
gouvernement point d'interrogation ?
Comment veux-tu que je réponde à ça ? Il
faut une justice très indépendante.
Il se trouve que je connais j'aime
j'aime j'aimais bien du pont Moretti.
Moi, c'est quelqu'un qui
personne n'est parfait, hein.
Non, non, mais je veux dire, bon, il dit
il dit des conneries comme tout le
monde, mais euh voilà. Et donc quand je
l'ai vu débarquer dans le casting
gouvernemental, je me suis dit tiens, il
va peut-être faire bouger des choses et
tout. Euh moi je je je sais pas. Je
pense que la justice c'est vraiment le
le le un chantier très très important,
c'estàd pour un gouvernement. J'ai
aucune confiance en Macron. Là, là, il
augmente un peu le budget de la justice,
mais la réponse à ces questions, c'est
la justice. C'est-à-dire que il faut des
des juges d'instruction indépendants. Il
faut que les parquets, ce qui est pas le
cas du tout, puissent ouvrir des
informations sur des tas de sujets. Il
faut qu'on puisse gratter sur le
patrimoine. Ça c'est des questions
importantes. Pourquoi ? Je connais plein
de politiques qui ont des patrimoines de
ouf et on va jamais voir comment ils ont
pu se payer telle maison, telle villa,
tel truc. Tu vois, je je vais recréer un
un nouveau média. Je te l'annonce ici.
On en on en parlera si tu veux. Mais
c'est un de mes champs de bataille, ça
va être ça dans le nouveau média,
c'est-à-dire développer des enquêtes et
cetera. Ce qui me navre une des choses
qui me navre le plus avec ce qui vient
de m'arriver au niveau du du média,
c'est que tout ce que j'ai initié depuis
1 an euh enquête investigation avec
Marcan Devel, avec Maxime Renéi, avec
Thierry Gado, avec Thomas Di Rouau, je
parle de très bons journalistes avec que
j'ai fait venir. Tout ça c'est c'est
effondré.
On parlera après.
Ouais. Non mais c'est triste parce et
donc moi la première chose que je veux
faire quand je vais recréer ce nouveau
média,
comment il se il s'appellera ?
Mais je sais pas, je suis en train de
chercher le nom, je suis en là, je suis
en phase complète de de recherche. J'ai
vraiment besoin de de
On revient, on revient dessus après.
Est-ce que tu as regardé le le discours
de de notre leader charismatique
Emmanuel Macron hier soir ?
Ouais, j'ai j'ai regardé ça. Ouais.
Alors maintenant, je vais te poser une
question. C'est pas une question, je
vais te demander de défendre Emmanuel
Macron sur son discours hier.
Est-ce que tu peux défendre notre
président ?
Là, tu me demandes un cours de théâtre.
Enfin, je sais pas,
je pense qu'il est pas responsable de ce
qui nous tombe sur la sur la gueule
quoi. Le Covid et les les attentats. Je
pourrais le défendre sur ce qu'il a dit
sur la liberté de la presse et sur la la
nécessité que la France soit
et je trouve dégueulasse évidemment ce
qu'Erdogan et la manière dont don ce qui
se passe l'attentat de Nice, enfin tout
ça c'est horrible. Donc je peux je peux
il y a des moments où tu vois, il y a
des moments où le discours qu'il fait en
Afrique tout au début quand il a été
élu, il a fait un discours euh en
Afrique qui était vraiment bien sur sur
l'Afrique. Enfin, on on ne pouvait
qu'être touché par ça. Après, à la
seconde, le traitement qui fait des
gilets jaunes, la manière dont ce
gouvernement ne tient que par la police,
les retraites et cetera, pour moi, c'est
le disqualifie à jamais. C'est-à-dire
plus jamais je ne pourrais voter pour
Emmanuel Macron. C'est une des pires
choses.
Voté Emmanuel Macron.
J'ai voté Emmanuel Macron. second tour
parce que je suis comme un paquet de
gens, c'est-à-dire c'était c'est
un castor.
C'est quoi un castor ?
C'est les gens qui font barrage.
Ouais, mais là, j'y crois plus du tout
quoi. C'est une c'est une catastrophe
pour pour ce pays, pour nous et cetera.
Alors, si tu me demandes de le défendre
sur la crise Covid,
je te le demande de le défendre hier sur
son euh discours.
Bah, je trouvais que le il a il était
moins pire que quand il a parlé de
guerre et cetera, mais tu sens que il
est il est dur à défendre parce que là,
j'y crois pas à son histoire de de de
confinement en en laissant les gamins
dans les écoles. C'est n'importe Moi,
j'ai un fils de 16 ans, je vois bien. Il
va être avec tous ses potes, on va aller
le chercher, il va rentrer à la maison.
Enfin, c'est c'est des nids à covid.
Va faire crever papi, c'est ça ? Comment
tu vas faire crever papi ? Je sais pas
mais mais euh enfin je veux dire tout
tous ceux qui ont des enfants à l'école,
on on peut se poser 1000 questions là en
fait. Tu sais je je suis bon quand
j'étais au médias et encore plus
aujourd'hui je suis bombardé
d'information de tous ces gens aussi qui
te disent euh le masque c'est des
conneries. Ce gouvernement essaie de
nous museler avec tout ça. C'est c'est
incroyable. c'est-à-dire les
conspirationnistes mais mais ça
représente énormément de gens hein. Et
donc moi moi je suis très inquiet,
c'est-à-dire que le je pense pas que le
Covid soit comme une grosse grippe. Je
pense que c'est des conneries. Je pense
que Raoul
Attends attends attends que tu penses
que c'est des conneries dans quel sens ?
Je pense que le Covid
et bien bien pire qu'une grippe.
Mais bien sûr. Mais bien sûr.
C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui quand tu
réfléchis à à ce qu'est ce virus, quand
tu lis, quand tu essaies de t'informer,
tu ne peux être qu'inquier. pas
seulement sur les histoires de lit
d'hôpitaux, de réanimation et cetera,
mais sur la nature même du virus.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ce virus qui se
cache, qui touche à la fois les enfants,
qui qui on est un symptomatique et puis
en même temps certains ont des ont des
dégâts neurologiques, d'autres bon il y
a les poumons, d'accord, enfin tu te
demandes ce qui peut arriver des des oui
des accidents cardiaques, des choses
comme ça et et on sait pas de de de quoi
demain sera fait quoi. Enfin, c'est et
donc il y a un problème aussi de on on
même si ce gouvernement fait vœux
d'information euh moi je suis j'y crois
pas quoi. C'estàd j'ai vraiment
l'impression qu'il y a des moments pour
ne pas nous inquiéter. On nous cache des
informations et pour des raisons aussi
vraiment économiques.
Dire que Macron a beau dire on peut pas
opposer santé économie, c'est ce qu'il
fait en permanence. C'est-à-dire que là,
il se dit puttin, si je confine
complètement, le pays va à la ruine. Et
en même temps, il choisit. Mon sentiment
après son discours, c'est qu'il choisit
plutôt l'économie que la santé, quoi.
Chois peut-être la France. Je vais me
faire l'avocat du diable puisque tu
arrives pas à à défendre notre leader
charismatique.
Euh pourquoi envoyer les enfants à
l'école ? Simple. B
c'est pour que les parents puissent
aller bosser. Voilà.
Non, mais non, mais ça ça c'est
l'explication à court termiste.
D'accord.
Pourquoi envoyer les enfants à l'école
maintenant ? Est-ce que tu te rappelles
d'Haïti où quand ils sont tapés un
tremblement de terre, les enseignants
sont fait ravager ? Il y avait plus
d'enseignant sur Haïti, d'ailleurs,
c'est toujours le cas. Et il y a eu un
un il y a eu un problème qu'on a nommé
les grands retardés, c'est-à-dire des
gamins 9 10 ans qui n'avaient que 450
mots de vocabulaire parce que il
n'avaient pas la capacité
il n'avait pas la capacité euh d'avoir
un système éducatif.
Est-ce que Macron, tu penses qu'il
envoie les gamins à l'école en première
ligne parce que il anticipe dans 10 ans
le fait qu'on se trouve avec des grands
retardés parce que des gamins qui auront
décroché, des gamins qui n'auront pas pu
avoir accès au au système éducatif d'une
façon correcte. Est-ce que tu penses pas
que là il limite la casse ? Il envoie
les gamins à l'école comme des petits
soldats pour que la France dans 10 ans
ne perde pas 10 points de PIB ?
Écoute euh je je je pense qu'on peut
penser ça, je pense pas qu'il ait pensé
ça. Je je crois que c'était plus
strictement basique et économique en se
disant si on on laisse les gamins à la
maison, les parents seront obligés de
rester et la machine économique va être
complètement euh enrayée. Je pense que
c'est ça son premier raisonnement. Mais
ça ça dit quelque chose aussi sur l'état
de notre système éducatif qui d'ailleurs
on peut on peut faire le parallèle avec
le le le le système de santé. Il a il y
a aucun investissement. C'estàd que
c'est un service public. Le le la France
au niveau éducation c'est complètement
défaillant. Blancaire peut faire des
grandes déclarations pour tout ce qui
est télétravail, téléenseignement,
ordinateur, enfin on est à la ramasse.
Le classement PISA nous nous relègue
tout le temps au au bas fond du truc.
Donc voilà, on on on paye aussi ça,
c'est-à-dire qu'on paye l'absence totale
d'investissement dans les services
publics, dans ces services publicslà et
et de de prévoyance. C'est un
gouvernement qui prévoit pas. là, il
avait le temps de de de c'est c'était
prévisible que que le peut-être pas à c
avec cette force-là, mais que l'épidémie
revienne. Donc, il fallait euh enfin
bon, après avec des sill euh je pense
qu'individuellement ces gens-là tu tu
passes une heure avec eux, ils vont être
assez convaincants. Mais c'est une sorte
de de système où on a l'impression que
c'est de c'est imprévoyant totalement.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a jamais de de
réflexion à long terme, que ça réagit
dans l'émotion au coup par coup et
cetera. J'ai j'ai moi j'ai ce ce
sentiment là quoi. Encore plus
d'ailleurs sur la les les questions du
terrorisme et de tout ça où on va
légiférer dans l'émotion et il y a rien
de pire.
Pour revenir aux parents qui vont
travailler, est-ce que tu penses pas que
Macron laisse les gens aller travailler
pour gérer en fait l'inertie du choc
économique qu'on est en train de se
taper ? C'estàd les parents qui vont
bosser gèrent euh la France le le
l'économie française tout de suite
maintenant. C'est qu'on les envoie en
première ligne face au Covid parce que
la crise économique qu'on risque de se
taper va être apocalyptique et que
Macron est en train de gérer la force du
choc économique et c'est pour ça qu'il
laisse les gens aller travailler.
Oui. Non mais là là oui sûrement.
C'est-à-dire que il on peut pas
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer là ? On le
voit bien avec les indépendants, les
restaurateurs, on a tous des copains qui
qui se demandent là le chômage
technique, ça ça va être bien mais je
veux dire à un moment la la machine va
être complètement essoufflée quoi. Donc
je c'est une une période qui est je vais
dire des conneries mais qui est qui est
hyper angoissante quoi. Y compris pour
pour enfin pour moi quoi. C'estàdire je
puis tu vois bien dans la rue quand tu
là tu prends le train, tu vois la tête
des gens, on est tous dans une on est on
est un peu plombé quoi. on se dit et
c'est surtout la défiance à l'égard de à
l'égard de ce gouvernement et puis quand
on voit arriver ce qu'on ce qui ce qui
se profile on on peut c'est flippant
quoi. Quand tu allumes ta télé, tu
tombes que sur des des fachot qui
viennent te dire il faut qu'on se
replie, il faut [__] les les étrangers
dehors, enfin et cetera. Tous ces
messages de haine qui commencent à
monter enfin qui tu as l'impression que
Trump a a infusé ici aussi quoi. Donc
c'est
pourquoi faire le parallèle avec Trump ?
Bah parce que écoute, j'ai j'ai enfin ça
a un rapport ce que je vais te dire.
J'ai lu le livre de de Fabricio Calvi
sur Trump et la mafia
qui est sorti chez Robert Lafond il y a
je crois c'est Robert Lafond il y a 6
mois qui est vraiment un livre
intéressant parce que c'est la première
fois d'une manière aussi précise on
explique comment Donald Trump est le
produit de la mafia sicilienne russe
aussi et tous ces liens avec des crimes
sordides et cetera, il s'en est toujours
tiré. Le bouquin est assez éclairant et
quand je l'ai lu, je me suis j'ai invité
Fabricio Calvi euh à faire un un grand
entretien dans mon émission du média.
C'est une des dernières que j'ai faite
qui s'appelle qui s'appelle TPA. Tout
peut arriver. C'est l'émission. On fait
l'émission et euh j'avais jamais vécu
ça. Euh donc l'émission passe sur
YouTube. Tu sais quand je fais des
certaines de mes émissions font
je faisais ouais euh font des des
fois on dépasse 2 millions de vues. Donc
on voit bien, je commence à être un peu
toi aussi tu tu fais ça avec Syerview
parce que tu vois bien le nombre de vues
que tu as. Et moi, c'est vrai qu'à un
moment donné, alors que c'est pas mon
monde au départ, je suis j'étais assez
accro à l'audience. Donc je vais assez
vite voir sur YouTube pour voir comment
ça décolle quoi. Et je peux te dire que
quand tu fais, je sais pas moi euh 50000
vues en 30 minutes, tu dis ben que tu es
peut-être parti pour faire un million.
Tu vois ce genre ce genre de chos là
quoi.
Fais pas ça pour l'audience. Non.
Non mais je fais pas Non mais d'accord,
tu fais pas ça pour l'audience mais tu
es plutôt content quand tu fais des
millions de vues. Non.
Donc là avec Trump, c'est un rapport
avec Le Pen et avec avec tout ça. Je je
vais y venir. Donc je je fais cette
émission que je trouve passionnante moi.
Et je vais sur YouTube et j'observe les
5 premières minutes. J'ai eu euh alors
je sais plus 120 pouces baissés, 25
commentaires négatifs en en 7 minutes.
Vous vous pouvez vérifier d'ailleurs sur
YouTube si vous tapez Trump et tout vous
tu retrouves les trucs. Et les 20
premières minutes, j'ai eu un raid comme
j'avais jamais vu de d'un moment j'avais
800 pouces baissés pour 150 pouces levé
quoi. Et puis des messages mais des des
centaines de messages négatifs. Un raid
sur une vidéo sur Trump que passe le
média enfin et cetera. Mais qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ? Et donc on a un peu
essayé de on a essayé de remonter
d'essayer de comprendre ce qui se
passait. Et donc il y a eu il y a donc
des robots. Ce que je veux dire par là,
c'est que la fachosphère est en train de
gagner la bataille de l'internet
et ce phénomène là qui qui est pas non
plus
c'est quoi la fâchosphère
la Non mais en tout cas ces gens-là qui
défendent Trump, j'appelle ça la
fâchosphère parce que on retrouve chez
les types qui nous qui nous attaquent
des militants du Rassemblement national
et des gens qui qui qui arrivent des
États-Unis qui écrivent dans un un c'est
pas des robots qui t'envoient des trucs,
c'est les mecs se se ils sont allés
alerté sur le fait qu'il y a une vidéo
sur un site de gauche, je sais pas quoi,
qui attaque Trump. Enfin, c'est ça qui
se passe. Et ils vont briser
l'algorithme qui aurait pu faire. Trump
aurait pu faire 2 millions de vues le
l'émission que j'ai faite avec Fabrizio.
Bah comme comme il brise le le le truc,
il brise rien du tout. Tu connais rien à
l'algorithme YouTube, ils brisent rien.
Ils te font encore plus de pub.
C'estàdire que quand tuas
Non, bah non, parce que ça moi c'est ce
qu'on m'a expliqué. C'est-à-dire que
comme il y a beaucoup de commentaires
négatifs, comme c'est sulfureux, comme
c'est YouTube ne ne pousse pas le truc.
Enfin, en tout cas, c'est c'est c'est ce
qui s'est passé et après c'est remonté.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'ils sont
très organisés, c'est que la bataille
pour l'information se joue sur les
réseaux sociaux beaucoup plus que que
que sur les télévision. Et donc, OK, il
y a des types comme Pascal Pro ou comme
C'est C News qui veut devenir le nouveau
Fox News qui qui font beaucoup
d'audience, mais c'est beaucoup plus
important de de enfin, je veux dire en
terme de de bascule. C'est pour ça m'a
fait marrer l'autre jour quand tu as vu
Pascal pro, il s'est foutu de la gueule
de de Daniel Sherman en disant le mec,
on va pas parler de lui, il est
insignifiant et cetera. Mais c'est c'est
pro ne se rend pas compte de la force de
l'internet. C'est lui par rapport à
internet quand il fait ses vidéos, il
fait il fait pas de vue. C'est lui qui
est quasi insignifiant par rapport à ça.
Enfin bref, je veux pas rentrer dans ce
débat-là mais ce que je voulais dire
c'est que si le Rassemblement national
parce que ils ont des types qui sont
formés pour ça quand Banon est venu en
France il a fait des stages d'initiation
avec ces mecs-là et et on on voit
comment ils font monter les polémiques.
J'ai bien étudié la la l'histoire du
voile à Dijon là, tu sais, il y a il y a
un petit fachot là qu'on voit partout
sur les chaînes de télé. Le mec qui fait
de la muscu, il a toujours des des
chemises. Il s'appelle Odoule, je crois,
un nom comme ça. Il est sur tous les
trucs.
Tu dis qu'il est fachou.
Mais parce que parce que tous les propos
qu'il a euh par rapport à l'immigration,
par rapport à l'État de la France, par
rapport à tout ça, c'est pour moi, je
les appelle comme ça. C'est un terme
générique qui signifie des types qui qui
qui réfléchissent avec des des des butés
et qui qui
pas la même chose à gauche, des mecs qui
s'organisent à gauche, qui font des
raides à gauche. Il y a pas la même
chose dans d'autres communautés. C'est
normal que je te que je te je te pousse
dans le retranchement. Non mais pas
comme ça que je vais
Non mais parce que alors alors si par
exemple tu veux faire un parallèle entre
Marine Le Pen et Mélenchon ce que les
gens font
beaucoup
non mais je trouve ça dégueulasse chaque
fois de de faire ça. Par contre, si tu
veux dire que des types de gauche, si
des types de gauche se comportent comme
des des gros connards ou des des des
patrons et tout ça, je je
je te pose la question. Est-ce qu'il y a
pas le le miroir à ce que tu appelles
les fachaot qui qui te rushent en raid ?
Est-ce qu'il y a pas la même chose à
gauche ?
Il y a des sortes de de mais ils sont
beaucoup moins organisés, beaucoup moins
influents, beaucoup plus grouusculaires.
Il y a des cryptocommunistes. Tu as
enquêté sur eux ? Non, mais je les ai je
les ai côtoyé. J'en ai côtoyé
quelques-uns de très près, tu vois. Et
bon euh ils ils sont plutôt euh bas de
plafond, quoi. Enfin, tu vois, c'est des
types qui réfléchissent assez peu qui
ont lu Marx mais comme un livre de
coloriage et et ça donne ça donne
n'importe quoi. D'ailleurs, je trouve
que c'est très étonnant pour moi.
Pareil, je vis quelque chose de
douloureux avec le média, mais ça m'en
apprend beaucoup aussi. C'était quand je
c'estd que des types qui te font des
leçons de morale qui passent pour des
parents de vertus et qui sont pour une
égalité de salaire se comporte
pire que le pire des des des patrons de
droite quoi. La manière dont ils m'ont
traité, c'est absolument horrible.
C'est-à-dire que c'est mais je bon je
pas forcément envie de parler de ça,
mais c'estàd que c'est des gens qui te
font des des leçons de morale en
permanence quand tu regardes leurs
émissions et cetera et et la manière
dont ils se comportent avec leur
salariés. Il y a pas que moi, il y en a
eu d'autres avant, il y en aura d'autres
après. C'est aucun respect pour les
conventions collectives, aucun respect
pour le droit du travail. C'est que
c'est ton interprétation.
Non, c'est la là franchement c'est la
réalité. C'estàd que là on verra la la
suite des procédures. Mais là donc tu
veux qu'on Moi, je veux
pas tout de suite.
Non non mais je voilà. Donc ne parlons
pas de ça.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé au médias ?
Ici c'est moi qui pose des questions.
D'accord.
Écoute, je veux je veux bien je veux
bien en parler mais comment dire
tu es pas obligé hein.
Si. Non non mais j'ai j'ai même envie
d'en parler.
Est-ce que c'était une bonne expérience
?
Alors j'ai passé 17 mois et demi enfin
j'ai commencé en avril 2019 jusqu'en
septembre de cette année. Formidable.
J'ai adoré faire ce que j'ai fait. J'ai
adoré.
Attends je je me permets encore de te
couper que je peux.
Euh donc tu es arrivé là-bas, ils
étaient en train de claquer si mes
souvenirs sont bons. C'est-à-dire que
Hael Lancelin était parti. Bah c'est il
viennent ils viennent me chercher à deux
en me disant moi faut faut dire à ce
moment-là je tout va bien pour moi.
J'écris des scénarios, j'ai un bouquin,
j'ai un un éditeur qui me commande un
livre avec enfin je gagne ma vie bien
mieux d'ailleurs que je la gagnerai
après. Mais enfin peu importe et ils
viennent me me voir et moi je suis
sociaux, c'est-à-dire que j'ai mis euh 5
€ ou 10 € enfin dans le média depuis le
début depuis Jikirou. enfin parce que je
trouvais que c'était bien de de
promouvoir cette télé là. Et donc j'ai
été interviewé par eux et quand ils
viennent me voir à deux, ils me disent
c'est vraiment une supplique.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils me disent si tu
viens pas, on est en train de crever.
Bon, moi je dis je veux bien mais je
veux pas je veux bien être président
d'un truc, essayer de vous aider de de
venir mais d'abord il faut qu'au de
Lancelin puisse revenir c'est-à-dire que
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé et cetera
quoi. Enfin et donc il m'explique, il me
disent des choses horribles sur elle et
je connaissais un peu au de lancelin.
J'ai du mal à à les croire. Donc ma
première réaction quand ils sont venus
me proposer le job euh a été d'appeler
au de lancelin quoi. Et aujourd'hui, je
comprends mieux dans quel état de ner
elle pouvait être mais elle m'a très
très mal accueilli. Elle elle a pensé
elle m'a accusé de d'avoir faumenté
contre elle pour gagner cette place.
Alors que c'est tout l'inverse si tu
veux. moi la veille qui vient de me
voir, j'avais j'avais jamais imaginé une
seconde devenir directeur de la
rédaction du média et m'investir autant
dans ce dans ce truc quoi. Et et me me
parle très très mal, elle m'injurit au
téléphone et donc si elle avait pas eu
cette attitude, peut-être que j'aurais
pas dit oui d'une manière aussi rapide
que ce que j'ai dit. Et donc elle a eu
cette attitude que je comprends mieux
aujourd'hui parce qu'elle était dans une
souffrance, une douleur, parce qu'elle
avait énormément travaillé. Après, je je
j'étais pas donc je connais mal je
connais mal ce qui s'est passé. Toujours
est-il que j'accepte le job et
en une semaine, je me retrouve face à
une il viennent me chercher,
je leur dis oui. Je réfléchis un petit
peu un petit peu avant et je réunis
toute l'équipe. Ça représente quand même
une quarantaine de personnes à mon truil
dans dans l'immeuble et je leur dis
voilà je suis je vais faire du mieux que
je peux. Je regarde l'état des finances.
Ils étaient quand même à je crois pas
d'information confidentielle. Non, c'est
pas confidentiel mais ils étaient dans
la archi dans la cave que alors j'ai mis
du temps à comprendre l'économie du
média. L'économie du média, c'est tous
les mois à peu près 100000 € de carte
bancaire qui tombent à peu près. Il y a
des mois où c'est 80000, des mois où
c'est 120000. C'est ce qu'on appelle les
sociaux, les gens qui qui euh qui ont
créé le média à l'origine il y a 3 ans
qui étaient effectivement des militants
de de autour de Mélenchon pour créer un
média de gauche. Mais très vite quand
quand Sopia Shikiro est partie, elle
aussi lourdée par les mêmes personnes
d'ailleurs qui me lourdent aujourd'hui
en partie, euh il y a il y a eu beaucoup
d'argent investi. Il y a eu
C'est quel régime fiscal ?
C'est une association.
Et avant c'était comment ?
C'était une association et là ça allait
plus ça va se transformer en
coopérative. C'est d'ailleurs la ce qui
m'arrive aujourd'hui est lié au passage
en coopérative. C'est une association
qui gère une boîte de production et une
entreprise de presse. Et moi, je suis
salarié de l'entreprise de presse.
Qui paye la TVA là-dedans ?
Bah la TVA, on en paye et on on se fait
rembourser. Euh ça passe ça ça facture
si tu veux le le l'entreprise de presse
facture. Enfin pas d'Af là. Moi moi je
les comptes étaient carrés.
Comment
quand tu as récupéré les choses les
comptes étaient carrés ?
Non. C'était compliqué au niveau de la
de la de la gestion. C'estàd qu'il y
avait pas de malversation, c'est pas ce
que je veux dire, mais c'était
complètement bordélique. La comptabilité
était mal organisée. Un un des premiers
des premières choses que j'ai qu'on a
fait, c'est c'est embauché euh une
personne hyper compétente qui a qui a
remis le le qui s'appelle Françoise.
Donc Françoise a remis ça sur sur les
rails et heureusement qu'elle était là.
Elle a elle a en particulier en partie
tous les deux plus quelques autres. on a
on a quand même sauvé la boîte quoi.
C'est-à-dire que elle était hyper
déficitaire, elle perdait de l'argent et
là quand quand je quand on m'a viré,
elle était à plus 500000 de de
trésorerie, tu vois. Donc c'estàd que
c'est une boîte qui tous les mois, il y
a des cartes bancaires qui qui qui
tombent. C'est un peu leur leur c'est
là-dessus qu'il vivent quoi. Et puis il
y a des campagnes il y a des campagnes
de de de dons qui qui réussissent
ont réussi grâce à ça à boucler l'année
et cetera et et depuis que j'y étais
arrivé, il y a eu beaucoup d'argent
quand même. C'estàd que tu voyais bien
quand je faisais des éditaux le
lendemain des éditaux, il était pas rare
que 10 15000 € tombent en en don. Voilà.
et tout ça, ça il y a des gens qui qui
qui ont donné beaucoup d'argent.
C'est-à-dire que il y a des je
d'ailleurs je dédie mon livre le Black
Rock, je dis à tous ceux qui qui d'une
manière altruiste financent les médias
indépendants. C'est très important les
médias indépendants. Et donc il y a des
gens qui ont donné parce que on pouvait
défiscaliser. C'est une des choses que
j'ai amené en passant par J'aime la
presse, on on on J'aime l'info pardon.
On on donne 1000 € au médias, on en
récupère 666, tu vois. Enfin, c'est euh
donc c'est des choses comme ça. J'ai le
le c'était pas florissant, mais on était
en train de gagner la partie.
C'est-à-dire que quand je suis arrivé,
il y avait peut-être 150000 adhérents.
Quand je repars, on est à 720000 ou 7400
adhérents entre YouTube et et Facebook.
Followers. Follower.
Followers. Ou enfin c'est des gens qui
qui Oui, followers. Donc donc voilà les
audiences les audiences si j'ai certains
de mes éditaux pendant le confinement on
fait plus d'un million de vues. Le le le
marque est changé je fais l'entretien
TPA comme toi ça fait 2 millions. On on
était presque en rivalité avec Syerview.
Enfin, je veux dire ça ça marchait bien
quoi. Et à un moment donné ce qui se
passe c'est que il donc il décide de
transformer le le le l'association
coopérative et je suis à fond d'accord
avec ça. C'est-à-dire que la le système
associatif avait trop duré. Donc il
fallait se transformer en coopérative
société coopérative à intérêt collectif.
C'était une très bonne idée. Donc ça
voulait dire faire venir des sociaux qui
prennent des décisions, que les salariés
prennent des décisions, à trouver un
système un petit peu comme ça. Et puis
là, j'ai pas donc enf il y a je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail mais il s'est
passé plusieurs choses. C'estàd qu'en
début d'année 2020, je fais un mail
absolument
candide. C'est-à-dire que je leur dis
voilà comment je vois les 6 mois à
venir. J'aimerais embaucher des des gens
dans l'investigation, j'aimerais qu'on
développe la culture. J'avais un
problème de rédaction de chef parce que
je faisais tout dans la dans je faisais
tout. C'est un peu il modeste que de
dire ça mais je c'était c'est une toute
petite équipe he il y a cinq
journalistes 8 ne pigistes. Il y a il y
a après il y a des monteurs, il y a de
l'administration et cetera. Il y a je
crois qu'il y a 26 ou 27 salariés plus
une douzaine de de d'intermittents du
spectacle ou de pigistement. Le budget
de fonctionnement de du média, c'est
combien
par mois ? C'est c'est autour de de de
entre 150 et 200000 €.
Est-ce que Est-ce que vous provisionniez
à l'époque euh pour faire du
documentaire date là quasiment ? Non,
mais on on arrivait pas mais on alors
justement donc je fais ce ce truc et là
je commence à sortir à sentir les
premiers les les les premiers
il y a eu une petite crise, une
angueolade et cetera. Je sens vraiment
des résistances alors que j'étais à fond
investi. Je travaillais vraiment
énormément. parce qu'on m'avait dit
quand ils sont venus me chercher, il
m'avait dit euh euh tu auras le temps de
continuer à écrire tes livres et cetera,
ce qui était pas le cas puisque j'étais
tous les jours, j'étais là, je n'ai
passé de tr jours à Paris, j'étais à
l'hôtel. Autrement, je travaillais chez
moi parce que pour faire un édito par
exemple,
tu payé combien ?
J'étais payé net 4700 balles. 4720 brut,
ça faisait un peu plus de 6000 balles.
Tu es riche quand même parce que
Schneiderman, il est payé que 4005.
Ouais, je dépasse Neiderman, je dépassé
et d'ailleurs ce salaire, c'est dingue
parce que c'est c'est ça a été le le le
début de la fin pour moi. Moi, je
trouvais pas que je gagnais beaucoup vu
l'investissement que je donnais.
À ton âge,
mais oui, à mon âge, mais comment dire,
j'ai jamais parce que là, ils ont
inventé un truc comme quoi j'étais
j'aurais voulu demander des
augmentations de salaires et cetera.
C'est c'est bon, j'ai pas envie d'être
chiant là-dessus, mais c'est très
important. C'est c'est à l'origine de
toute la crise et de et de tout ce
bordel et ça montre leur leur
obscurantisme et et euh
je trouve qu'ils sont obscurs
est-ce qu'ils ont des choses à te
reprocher parce que j'ai alors mais non
mais ils m'ont reproché cette histoire
de salaire mais ce qui s'est passé et ça
il y a j'ai des traces tout ce que je
dis est documenté c'est-à-dire que rien
de ce que je dis ici n'est pas documenté
tout blanc dans l'histoire
oui bah tout blanc ça veut rien dire je
me suis trompé sans doute parce que j'ai
j'ai pas vu venir un certain nombre de
choses Le 11 septembre quand j'ai eu ma
lettre, une sorte de lettre qui me
demande de de d'être rétrogradé du poste
de directeur de la rédaction. Elle est
incroyable cette lettre quand on la
relit. Comment comment pouvait-il
imaginer une seconde que j'accepte ces
critiques complètement débiles selon
lesquelles j'étais un harceleur ou tout
ça tout ça est faux. C'est une
construction qui a été faite après. Mais
j'en reviens à l'origine du truc.
L'origine du truc, c'est que euh il
décide dans le règlement intérieur,
enfin dans les statuts de la nouvelle
coopérative, de faire une échelle de
salaire de 1 pour 3. C'est-à-dire que le
le plus gros salaire doit pas être plus
de trois fois supérieur que le le le
plus petit. Et à ce moment-là, je leur
dis c'est simplement pas possible
puisque moi le le contrat que j'ai fait
avec vous est une sorte de contrat à
mi-temps, même si je travaille à temps
complet et que il faut que vous preniez
le salaire complet, c'est-à-dire que
c'était plus presque 10000 € pour pour
évaluer le le premier des salaires. il
me dit non, tu dis n'importe quoi. On
fait faire donc ça voulait dire que tous
les les salaires de de base, si on est
sur un truc de 1 pour 3 sont supérieurs
à 3000 €. Ça voulait dire que à la
rentrée de septembre, je pouvais pas
embaucher un nouveau rédacteur en chef.
Je pouvais pas embaucher
les les Maxime Renay que je voulais
embaucher. Je pouvais pas payer les
pigis comme je voulais les payer parce
que il fallait augmenter tous les
salaires. Moi, je ne demandais
pas président.
Non, je suis pas président. Moi
justement, j'ai pas voulu de j'ai pas
voulu. pas à toi de prendre ce genre de
d'initiative.
Non, mais moi je suis directeur de la
rédaction, je suis responsable du
développement de de la boîte et je suis
responsable de l'éditorial. Donc c'était
c'était important, c'était mon rôle de
faire ça. Et là, il y a commencé à y
avoir des blocages idéologiques à la
noix, quoi. Parce que sous prétexte que
c'était un pour trois, donc là le le le
président de l'association a organisé un
vote que je qualifie de bidon.
Pourquoi ?
Mais pourquoi ? Est-ce que c'était pas
un vote ? Qui a voté ce ce cette échelle
de salaire de 1 pour 3 ? Il a été
cherché des gens par exemple les
pigistes réguliers n'ont pas voté mais
il y a des monteurs qui étaient
intermittents qui ont voté. Donc on
arrivait à un vote. Il a pas eu raison à
faire à créer un vote. C'est bien c'est
parti. parce que c'est c'est mais le
vote, il aurait dû être organisé d'une
manière différente. Il a été fait à la
sauvage et il y a eu 15 15 voix je crois
de mémoire, deux abstentions et 10
personnes qui ont voté contre cette
échelle de 1 pour 3. À partir de ce
moment-là, ça a été très compliqué parce
que
ils ont mis en place ce ce système là et
donc il y a enfin après on rentre dans
des choses qui sont il a il a fallu si
tu veux moi j'étais j'étais embauché sur
le même contrat qu'au de Lancelin, c'est
un contrat sur 175 jours dont je me suis
rendu compte il y a peu de temps que je
qu'il avait pas été signé ce contrat
parce que tout est bordélique au médias
à commencer par les contrats tout ça et
tout tout est un peu on a vigue à vu
quoi. L'inspection du travail elle fait
quoi ? et ben l'inspection du travail là
je évidemment j'ai je porte pleinte au
prudom je suis pas d'accord avec mais tu
vas comprendre le le le l'ignominie dans
laquelle je suis face à laquelle je suis
je suis parce que tout ce que je dis
encore une fois je le dis sans colère
sans haine. Je c'estàd que je ces gens
je les vois comme des voilà je les vois
voilà la manière dont il dont ils m'ont
maltraité. Je suis absolument maltraité
dans cette dans cette histoire. Je ne me
plains pas.
Tu pens être maltraité ?
Non je je l'ai été. Je peux te je peux
te le démontrer de de cette manière-là
puisque ça fait quand même 18 mois que
je que que je bosse. Et donc j'avais ce
contrat là et comme ils ont posé cette
cette question d'échelle des salaires,
c'est pas moi qui l'ai posé. Ce sont
eux. On a dû commencer à à compter les
jours. Euh ça s'appelle un time sheet,
tu es obligé, l'inspection du travail
t'oblige à rendre compte de ton temps de
travail. Et donc moi, mon temps de
travail était effectué, c'est-à-dire que
j'avais effectué à la fin du mois
juillet 186 jours de de travail. Donc
j'étais je pouvais être payé jusqu'à la
fin de l'année puisque c'était un
contrat sur l'année. Donc je leur ai
demandé
parce que je voulais continuer à faire
des éditaux, je voulais continuer à
travailler un peu des des augmentations
de jour. Certains étaient d'accord,
d'autres pas d'accord. Et donc je me
suis dit, je laisse passer l'été. Je
j'ai écrit mon bouquin sur Black Rock.
Euh j'étais en contact avec eux. On
était en désaccord sur un certain nombre
de de de choses. Je voyais bien qu'ils
étaient en train de tramer. Eux sont
restés tout l'été à à monter des des
plans. En fait, ils avaient je pense
qu'ils avaient une ils avaient le projet
de m'évincer, mais il pensaiit que
peut-être j'allais rester pour toucher
mon salaire, être un peu comme Cavana
avec Philippe Val, une espèce de potige
qui vient faire un édito. Mais je
pouvais pas assumer si tu veux, il y a
des choses dans j'étais directeur de la
rédaction, ça veut dire je suis
responsable de de l'éditorial. Il y a
des il y a des donc il y a des il y a
des des choses sur lesquelles je dois
donner mon avis. J'ai jamais été
quelqu'un d'autoritaire. J'ai toujours
été euh conciliant avec eux. J'ai essayé
de discuter et cetera. Le 11 septembre,
je reçois une lettre. J'apprends que je
suis brutal dans ma dans ma manière de
manager, que l'équipe
veut veut créer de l'horizontalité.
Enfin, il y a tout un tas de griefes qui
me sont
C'est légitime l'horizontalité
dans une rédaction.
Non, mais ça ça dépend de ce qu'on Moi,
j'étais plutôt pour l'horizontalité,
c'est-à-dire que chacun chacun est à peu
près autonome, mais quand tu quand tu as
une rédaction, tu es bien obligé d'un
moment donné de trancher, de poser. Là
là récemment, ils ont eu un débat en
interne euh où effectivement ils ont
décidé horizontalement d'inviter
quelqu'un et la la l'actuelle direction
a posé son véto par exemple, il y a des
moments où
c'était qui ? euh c'était le CICF et euh
donc ils ont ils l'ont fait quand même
mais à un moment donné ceux qui ceux qui
veulent de l'horizontalité ont dit non
il est hors de question d'inviter euh le
le type du CICF donc euh des conflits,
ils en auront, ils vont en avoir. Mais
moi je leur souhaite bonne chance si tu
veux. Je suis pas du tout dans un truc
béliqueux avec eux. C'est-à-dire que il
fallait qu'on se quitte bons amis à la
limite. Plus de moi, je me casse.
CF le CCF pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas c'est quoi ?
Je sais plus le sigle, c'est euh le le
le type qui lutte contre le le
l'islamisme, contre le le le racisme
anti-islamique.
C'est ça.
On laissera la communauté fatchéqui, on
vient de passer un slide.
Ouais, mais je suis pas Donc non, mais
là, tu me prends de cours, je voulais
simplement en finir là-dessus. Le 11
septembre, je je reçois cette lettre, ça
a été mon 11 septembre à moi. Et puis
après, ben je vois que moi, si tu veux,
on on me laisse pas m'exprimer. Donc euh
donc je fais une vidéo pour dire
"Écoutez, je suis pas d'accord là en
plus si tu veux pour le passage en
coopérative, ils sont en train de
museler un voté.
La vidéo c'était euh ton licenciement
pour de fautees grave." C'est ça.
C'est ça. Ils ont utilisé cette vidéo
alors que non c'est pas normal. C'est de
la liberté d'expression. Je On me laisse
pas m'exprimer.
Dans ton contrat, il y avait marqué ça ?
Non, justement, j'ai le droit de
m'exprimer. Mon contrat m'autorise à
m'exprimer. C'est-à-dire j'ai absolument
le droit de m'exprimer. les les
prudhommes vont évidemment enfin je veux
pas présumer de ce qu'ils vont dire mais
mais ça va et voilà, je veux dire, j'ai
le droit de m'exprimer à un moment
donné, on ne me laisse pas m'exprimer.
Il y a une chose absolument pharamineuse
qui s'est passée quand même la semaine
dernière, c'est c'est elle est quand
même euh corsée cette mais enfin je je
termine là-dessus. Ouais. Donc donc je
fais ça, après je reçois une lettre de
licenciement où on raconte des trucs.
Alors je te donne simplement une
anecdote. Comme ils ont rien à à
m'opposer à part cette vidéo, ils sont
allés chercher
un procès en sexisme. C'est que ils sont
remontés 9 mois auparavant. Ils ont ils
ils ont ils ont mis les noms d'ailleurs
de deux filles que j'aurais avec
lesquels j'aurais été sexiste. Les deux
filles étaient pas au courant, les deux
jeunes filles. Donc là, elles ont
démenti.
C'est ces deux anecdotes de rien du
tout. Je pas envie de rentrer dans les
détails mais tu vois où ils en sont.
Donc OK, il me vire pour pour pour tout
ça, mais il me vire sans indemnité,
sans préavis, en ne me payant pas les
les mois qui me doivent de salair et et
voilà. Et il me file pas là au moment où
je te parle, j'ai toujours pas mon sol
de de tout compte. J'ai été licencié il
y a un mois. Je peux pas m'inscrire à
Pôle Emploi, je peux pas faire valoir
mes droits, enfin rien du tout. C'est
qu' ils en ont rien à [__]
C'est-à-dire qu'il ils décident, c'est
la politique de la de la terre brûlée.
Et ce qui se passe la semaine dernière,
c'est que je suis tellement je je alors
ce qui se passe premièrement, c'est que
le le mon employeur, le président de la
société de presse me contacte via un des
enfin un des fondateurs
qui s'appelle Henry Poulin que tu
connais enfin qui Henry m'appelle, il me
dit "Voilà, je viens d'avoir ton
employeur Julien Terry qui sort d'une
réunion de la rédaction et Julien
aimerait que tu que tu reviennes au
médias, c'est bien. Ah bah, je trouve
ça, je me dis super, enfin super,
attendons de voir parce que quand même
ça faisait un moment que que ça se
passait ça se passait très moyen et
tout. Donc on fait
une réunion Skype tous les trois et donc
on discute
et Julien Terry me me il est un peu sur
la réserve mais il dit bon bah il faut
qu'on discute.
Ça c'est ta ta version et ton
interprétation. Non mais le le
je prends des pincettes.
Non mais qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te
dise ? Je l'ai je la la j'ai les preuves
de tout ça. Enfin donc c'est j'ai même
pas envie je rentre peut-être dans des
détails qui n'ont pas lieu d'être mais
je j'ai pas envie de faire chier les
gens avec ça. Mais il y a tellement de
choses dégueulasses qui se sont passées
qu'au bout d'un moment je suis bien
obligé de de de d'intervenir et
d'expliquer aux sociaux parce que moi ma
seule préoccupation là-dedans, c'est les
gens qui financent le média. tous ces
gens qui à mon sens se font avoir, ils
s'en rendent compte aujourd'hui.
C'est-à-dire qu'on utilise leur argent,
leur cotisation et cetera pour créer une
sorte de de de communauté comme ça de
qui s'appelle le le média où les types
s'en foutent de ce que pensent les
sociaux. D'ailleurs, ça interprétation.
Mais non, parce que même sur le le
réseau
il ils disent ça, ils disent
tu tu enfin il y a un forum sur lequel
les sociaux s'expriment quoi et à un
moment donné les sociaux disent "Mais
ils étaient dans une grande grande
majorité opposé à mon à mon à mon
départ", tu vois. Et et on leur dit
"Non, mais c'est les salariés qui
doivent décider et cetera." Écoute, je
Et alors ce qui s'est passé la semaine
dernière, c'est que il y a eu cette
réunion de cette tentative de
conciliation. Moi je les ai écouté, on
devait se revoir lundi et lundi, ils
m'ont dit "Non, non, on se con on ne
concilie plus." Et au moment c'estàd que
quelques heures après que je fasse cette
conciliation, j'avais mon solde tout
compte sans préavis, sans rien, enfin et
cetera. Ce qui est complètement illégal,
je le prouverai dans les tribunaux enfin
et cetera. Mais eux, enfin, je veux dire
au prudom, ça ça va être une déferlente.
Je suis pas le seul, mais il ils se
comportent tellement mal que que voilà,
je suis obligé de de de me défendre.
Donc, j'écris sur le forum
du tout, je suis pas du tout
diffamatoire. Je dis voilà ce qui
m'arrive, je suis viré pour celle de
tout compte. La semaine dernière,
j'avais une réunion d'une tentative de
conciliation. Je comprends pas leur
attitude. En substance, je dis ça. Mon
truc est resté 10 minutes et il a été
censuré, banni. Et donc après
été banni,
ils appellent ça comme ça. Je reçois à
un moment donné au bout de 15 minutes de
mise en ligne, je reçois un message qui
me dit "Vous êtes banni, je peux plus me
m'exprimer sur le sur le forum."
Il y a d'autres personnes qui ont été
bannies s'ils ont aidé ?
Non. Alors alors ce qui s'est passé que
moi étant banni, bon ben voilà, je suis
banni quoi. Après j'ai mis mon truc sur
Facebook sur mon mur. Tous les gens qui
veulent vérifier peuvent le trouver.
C'est en excès libre. Et euh et là les
les les sociaux, enfin certains sociaux
qui avaient fait des captures d'écran
mais moi j'étais pas au courant de tout
ça, commence à republier mon mon
message,
voilà et il y a une chaîne comme ça qui
se crée chaque fois qu'il y avait un mec
qui publie, paf, il se fait bannir
aussi. Je sais pas combien ont été
bannis, mais 10, 15, 20, peut-être plus,
je sais pas quoi. Et donc ils se sont
mis mis à dos.
C'était peut-être diffamatoire pour eux.
C'était pas diffamatoire mais pas une
seconde diffamatoire mais il qu'ils
attaquent en diffamation. Je veux dire
euh c'est ce que eux disent n'est pas ce
que j'écris n'est pas diffamatoire. Par
contre, ce que eux disent de moi est
vraiment diffamatoire. Donc ils vont
avoir de mes nouvelles bientôt. Je suis
en train d'y d'y d'y travailler et mais
je suis pas du tout béliqueux mais au
bout d'un moment, tu vois, moi je suis
pas adepte de la deuxième joue quoi. Tu
vois les mecs les mecs et ça ça m'a
donné une sorte de donc avant le 11
septembre je pensais pas du tout euh à
créer un nouveau média.
Je je pensais que ça allait mieux se
passer au niveau du média, mais on était
en train de construire quelque chose de
tellement magique, de tellement
incroyable en terme d'audience, en terme
d'investigation, les les enfin tout ce
qu'on pratiquement tout ce qu'on faisait
avec Mathias Sentoven, avec d'autres, je
suis pas tout seul làdedans, mais parce
qu'ils veulent tout le temps me
straciser, mais si on prend les pigistes
et on est 5050 si tu veux, il y a des
gens qui m'aiment pas, il y a des gens
qui qui enfin c'est même pas un problème
d'affa
C'est un problème de Je pense que
j'étais à la fois victime de ce que
j'appelle les cryptocommunistes,
c'est-à-dire des gens qui sont
complètement idéologues et qui qui les
salaires, pas de tête qui dépasse, pas
de leader et cetera et puis et puis des
gens qui ont peur qui ont eu peur pour
leur emploi, qui ont eu peur parce que
je faisais des journalistes nouveaux qui
qui travaillaient différemment enfin et
cetera et donc ils se sont dit ou là là
ça va pas aller, on peut pas le on peut
pas le laisser faire tout ça. Mais moi
en plus j'étais hyper collectif, je
voulais qu'on en discute et cetera. On
m'en a pas laissé le temps. Donc là, je
suis hyper motivé mais comme jamais pour
recréer un nouveau média.
Attends, attends, avant avant que tu
nous annonce la création de d'un de d'un
nouveau canard,
tu penses pas que tu as fait une erreur
au managerial ?
Vraiment non. Vraiment non. J'ai je vois
pas comment j'étais pas là par exemple,
ils disent que que je pratiquais le le
certains m'ont accusé de harcèlement.
Enfin, je veux dire en 6 mois depuis le
Covid, j'ai dû aller trois fois au
médias quoi. Et j'ai dû en
télétravail télétravail.
Oui, j'étais en télétravail et j'ai
jamais autant travaillé que pendant le
télétravail. C'estd qu'au début, je
pensais travailler moi. Donc, je me suis
dit euh tiens, je vais me mettre un
mi-temps. Et très vite, je me suis rendu
compte que je travaillais. Je veux dire,
un édito ça prend 4 jours, un entretien
ça prend 2 jours. Il fallait gérer les
équipes, gérer les enquêtes et cetera.
J'ai jamais autant travaillé que pendant
le Covid. d'ailleurs de de de le chômage
à temps partiel est devenu un un travail
à temps plein. Donc j'ai énormément
bossé et c'està-dire j'étais tellement
mobilisé par par ce travail par parce
que écrire écrire ces éditaux ça me
prenait énormément d'énergie et de temps
que je me suis pas soucié moi de de de
où j'ai eu tort c'est que j'aurais dû
sans doute être plus attentif discuter
avec eux mais j'avais j'aurais jamais
imaginé qu'il monte un plan aussi aussi
pourri contre moi quoi. Enfin, je je
suis tombé de de de bon, c'est ma
naïveté. Je quand je suis arrivé le 11
septembre, je pensais vraiment pas qu'
qu'il ferait ça. Et ça été
faire l'avocat du diable pour toi.
Pardon ?
Je peux me faire l'avocat du diable ?
Vas-y.
Je sais que je t'ai beaucoup et que tu
aimes pas ça.
Non, non, mais si je te je te Au
contraire,
ça fait ça fait combien d'années qu'on
se connaît ? Depuis 2007.
Est-ce que en terme de d'erreur
managériale, Denis Robert, force de
travail colossale,
une brute de travail qui débarque dans
une toute nouvelle rédaction avec des
petit c'était des petit
Il y a un peu de ça. Ouais.
Et toi, tu arrives, tu as essayé de les
tirer vers le haut, tu as essayé de les
d'y aller à fond et et ils ont peut-être
ils sont fait peut-être écraser par ta
force de travail. Ils étaient peut-être
pas habitués. C'était
Mais en quoi c'est une erreur ça ?
C'est bah c'est des Pou. Il faut faire
attention avec les Pichou.
Mais je pense que je pense que j'ai je
si tu veux individuellement, c'est là
aussi où j'étais vraiment blessé
personnellement. C'està-dire que je
pense surtout aux journalistes aux 5 si
journalistes avec qui j'étais en
contact. Ils le savent bien,
c'est-à-dire individuellement, je peux
les regarder chacun dans les yeux. Ils
savent très bien que j'ai pas fait ce
qu'ils disent, ce que j'ai fait. Et eux
se sont fait à mon sens, ils sont
rentrés dans une sorte de processus. Ils
ont créé un syndicat. Ils ont demandé
mon départ. Enfin, tout ça et tout ça se
se réglera malheureusement au Prudom et
au pénal aussi puisque je vais déposer
un certain nombre de plaintes. Mais je
suis obligé d'en arriver là puisque
attends, il y a un truc quand même grave
euh je l'ai expliqué et je peux
facilement le prouver. C'est qu'ils ont
pratiqué à mon égard du harcèlement. Ils
ont attenté d'une manière répétée à ma
réputation. C'est-à-dire que euh euh ils
ont ils avaient pas le droit de dire ou
d'écrire un certain nombre de choses
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont dit de moi. Ils
n'avaient pas le droit. Le droit et je
je je ils se seraient excusé, on aurait
parlé. Ce que j'ai essayé de faire quand
même et Henri Poulin pourra en
témoigner. Je j'espère. Ils il a bien vu
dans quel état d'esprit j'étais. Mais
là, je suis face à des gens qui sont
complètement euh tu sais, c'est Wako, tu
vois la secte. Non, tu peux pas
comparer.
Non, mais non, mais je je ce que je veux
dire, c'est que ils se replient sur
eux-mêmes, il ils tendent le dos et euh
c'est en sens ce que je veux dire. Il y
a il y a il y a quelque chose d'assez
sectaire euh euh chez un certain nombre
de ces personnes. Ils vivent dans dans
cette dans un à Montreuil. Moi, j'ai
amené du sangu de l'oxygène, des choses
un petit peu nouvelles et eux, ils sont
absolument agressés. Il y a il y a tout
le monde leur tombe dessus. vue
hein.
C'est mon point de vue et je le partage.
Non mais quand je dis Wo, je veux pas du
tout. C'est une image, tu vois quand
quand les mecs se sont repliés
à l'intérieur d'une maison et puis tout
le monde a essayé de les les les
beaucoup de gens les les agressai et eux
il y a il y a un phénomène de de
pas l'impression. Tu as pas l'impression
parce que d'un avis extérieur ça fait
penser à un couple qui s'aime mais qu'il
se déchire. Non, je l'ai je
peut-être oui parce que je j'ai vraiment
aimé travailler avec eux euh avec tous
quoi. Et je trouve qu'on faisait du bon
boulot et je comprends pas pourquoi ils
ont tout cassé comme ça. Aujourd'hui
même, je n'arrive pas à le comprendre.
Eux, ils t'aiment aussi ?
Non, je suis pas sûr là. Enfin, en tout
cas,
les signes qui qui m'envoient, la
manière dont ils m'ont licencié et
cetera, c'est pas c'est pas une preuve
d'amour, c'est une preuve de je sais pas
quoi. Je pense que c'est la peur qui les
qui les motive.
Alors, question internet euh euh ça a
été vérifié ces questionsl.
Alors, en lim en lim Jean Denis Robert,
le la pseud entre guillemets la ça vient
d'internet, c'est pas de nous, hein. La
direction enterre le média TV. Cette
équipe plein de talent avec Serge
Faubert, Maxi Bren le stratégiste
Marcandeveld
est opérationnel. Ça c'est pas une
question les gars, c'est c'est pas une
c'est Allez hop, désolé.
Non non non, je vais revenir à
à mon fil. Donc maintenant tu tu crées
un nouveau canard, un nouveau journal,
un nouveau média, un nouveau quoi ?
Écoute, je
la formule la formule qu'on a qu'on a
mis en place aux médias fonctionne. On
on je sais comment maintenant avec des
monteurs, avec des journalistes, je sais
comment fabriquer de le enfin fabriquer
des programmes. Je veux être dans la
continuité de ce que j'ai fait au
médias. C'estàd je vais pas
révolutionner le je je vais reconstruire
mais ça prend du temps. J'ai besoin du
soutien de des gens parce que je je
repars de quasiment de zéro quoi. Donc
je mon mon idée c'est de de de là à
partir de de j'y pense maintenant depuis
un mois, j'ai commencé à prendre des
contacts. J'aimerais que des gens du
média, certains me me rejoignent et et
il y a des gens comme surtout en terme
d'investigation, d'enquête et tout ça et
tout tous ceux qui avec qui je
travaillais déjà en médiia vont venir
travailler avec moi. Je pense à Maxime,
j'espère Marc Andel et et les autres
plus des gens nouveaux. On va
recommencer les éditaux, on va on va
faire on va faire ce qu'on sait faire
quoi. Et voilà, donc je suis en train tu
as le droit de faire ça. Est-ce qu'il y
a pas un contrat, une clause de non
concurrence ? Non, non, non. B
évidemment, j'ai le droit dans le
contrat. Est-ce qu'il y a Est-ce qu'il y
a une clause de non concurrence dans ton
contrat ?
Pas du tout. Non non mais je le le
contrat en plus c'est le le contrat du
média c'est enfin bref, j'ai pas envie
de de revenir sur le passé mais
qu'est-ce que tu vas apporter au paysage
médiatique avec
Ah ben je je pense qu'on peut je pense
qu'on était en train de on était en
train de gagner la partie si tu veux.
Donc je vais reprendre la partie à
l'endroit où je l'ai laissé.
C'est-à-dire qu'avec des avec des
éditaux euh avec avec du reportage, avec
toutes toutes ces émission de débat, moi
en plus j'amenais j'amenais vraiment de
l'ouverture. Je suis un des des premiers
à avoir invité des gens de droite de la
République enfin je j'aime le débat,
j'aime la confrontation, je voilà et
puis et puis sur Macron, les gilets
jaunes et cetera, j'avais très envie de
de de j'ai très envie de continuer
là-dessus. Donc voilà, il y a un lien
qui va qui va s'afficher à la à la fin.
Je je lance une newsletter aujourd'hui
euh et on va euh contacter les gens, on
va créer cette communauté. Moi, j'ai
besoin du du soutien de tout le monde là
en ce moment euh pour qu'on pour qu'on
puisse créer au plus vite ce nouveau
média. Je suis en train de chercher un
nom, on a plusieurs on a plusieurs
pistes. Ça va être à la fois donc un
site d'information, une une web télé
et voilà quoi. Donc donc je suis à fond,
je suis à fond là-dessus. Je pense qu'à
ça. Je je me lève le matin, je pense à
ça. Je me couche le soir, je pense à ça.
Je suis vraiment dans la construction de
ce de ce nouveau média. Et je pense que
les les les sociaux, je suis aussi
poussé par les sociaux. Les sociaux par
centaines me demandent de faire ça. Donc
au bout d'un moment, je suis obligé de
les entendre. Allez sur ma page
Facebook, vous verrez t tous les les les
les messages que je reçois. Enfin, donc
je on était en train de gagner la
partie. Donc, je vais la reprendre et on
va la gagner la partie. Je pense que au
plus tard, en janvier ce ce le nouveau
média va démarrer. Mais on va lancer une
campagne de souscription, on va je suis
en train de le mettre en place mais pour
l'instant c'est pour l'instant je suis
dans dans la création de du truc.
Ce nouveau mé ce nouveau média,
j'ai dit quoi ?
Le nouveau média.
Ce nouveau média, oui, le nouveau parce
que parce qu'il va prendre sa place dans
le paysage.
Alors, question internet. Quel est
l'avenir de l'information ? La presse
papier va-t-elle survivre ? Peut-on
avoir une presse non subventionnée ?
Peut-on avoir une presse non dépendante
d'un oligarque ?
Oui, bah on en est la preuve la preuve
vivante, c'est-à-dire que nous, on était
vraiment devenu et c'est ce que je
voudrais qu'on qu'on soit à nouveau, une
une web télé de service public.
C'est-à-dire que on était financé. J'ai
découvert à à par mon passage au médias
la générosité totale de des gens euh des
des gens qui ont compris que
bah là les gens payaient non pas pour
s'abonner à un truc euh c'est pas média
part hein le le truc c'est il payait
pour que pour qu'on crée une télé qui
qui s'ouvre au monde et qui sort des
informations qu'on trouve pas ailleurs.
tous ces invités qu'on a eu et qu'on va
encore avoir qui sont pas dans les
médias mainstream et nous on on était en
train de le devenir mainstream. Quand tu
fais 2 millions de vues ou un million de
vues, tu tu peux plus tu es tu es tu es
tu es tu peux pas être considéré comme
comme marginal quoi.
Ouais, elle nous regarde, on fait on
fait pas grand-chose et on est toujours
marginal. On en profite, on en profite
pour dire merci à ceux qui nous
financent. Ça ça nous permet de faire du
documentaire bientôt et parce que nous
il faut qu'on fasse aussi des petites
annonces et euh et on vous réserve des
belles surprise les gars et merci pour
votre soutien. Avant que tu nous nous
lises un passage, j'en profite pour te
caser une nouvelle question pendant que
tu cherches ta page. Question :
anticorps craint que son agrément lui
soit lui permettant de saisir la justice
ne soit pas renouvelée. Il en pense quoi
? a été agréé par le ministère de la
justice. Bah j'ai il se trouve que j'ai
fait un entretien avec Éise Van Bedenan
qui qui est qui est la présidente
d'anticorps et qui est devenue mon mon
avocate parce que d'avoir une très bonne
avocate et elle me elle me défend au
prudom et je trouvais que c'était bien
que qu'une une une combattante comme
elle de la lutte anticorruption me me
représente parce que c'est une forme de
de lutte anticorruption que je je fais
aussi quoi. Et donc je pense je ne pense
pas que le gouvernement ira jusque-là.
J'ai confiance. Ce que je te disais
c'est qu'à un moment donné si Dupont
Moretti garde des sauts savilie au point
de ne pas accorder l'habilitation à
anticorps, c'est franchement la négation
totale de de qui il est et de ce qu'il
est. Il peut pas faire ça. C'est-à-dire
c'est le le mal sera sera sera terrible
parce que on peut anticorps aujourd'hui
est devenu complètement nécessaire au
paysage. C'est s'il y avait pas
anticorps, il y a plein d'affaires qui
ne sortiraient pas. Anticorps est une
est une association qui est qui qui est
qui d'ailleurs qui remplace les
parquets. C'est que les parquets qui
sont aux ordres de de cet état macronien
pour la la plupart anticorp quand il
constituent partie civile dans des
affaires de corruption, bah il ils
permettent à ce que des affaires
sortent, à ce que des juges se
saisissent et cetera. Heureusement, il
reste encore aussi des magistrats
indépendants qui jugent.
Il y a plein d'affaires qui qui sont
sorties et qui vont sortir. Oui. Je je
j'avais sorti ça parce que je j'ai aussi
créé enfin j'ai participé à la création
du CNNR cette année, c'est de le le
Conseil national de la nouvelle
résistance et et il sort un livre qu'on
trouve en COS qui vend du 3,90 € et qui
finance ce ce conseil et c'est Pablo
Serving qui l' en particulier écrit et
sur l'information il dit c'est c'est
assez pas banal mais il dit
l'information est devenue marchandise
une marchandise de plus en plus frolatée
de plus en plus ouvertement et
massivement au service des puissants.
C'est c'est une petite phrase mais il y
a tout un développement là-dessus et
c'est vrai que le paysage
en terme d'information est devenu
tellement euh euh nausé à bon. Alors je
sais quand je dis ça, moi j'ai des
copains journalistes qui travaillent à
France Interre, qui travaillent y
compris à BFM, qui travaillent au point,
qui travaillent à l'Express. Il y a des
gens qui vraiment essaient de faire le
taf au monde. Je pas tous les citer à
Libération et tout mais on sent
au médias aussi. au médias aussi bien
sûr, mais on sent bien que la tendance
générale est à la marchandisation. On
sait bien que tous ces médias
appartiennent à des oligarques qui ont
fait la promotion de Macron, que Macron
a été placé là et c'est le préfier de
Ran Branco qui dit ça. C'est-à-dire que
voilà, c'est c'est quand même une
réalité. Aujourd'hui, on on a un
président qui a d'abord été choisi par
des oligarques qui a qui ont ils ont mis
à son service des médias qui se sont
complètement écrasés et aujourd'hui
parfois tu as des véléités à l'intérieur
de ces médias. Mais c'est pour ça que
pour nous, pour cette ce projet que j'ai
de de de fabriquer ce nouveau média,
j'ai envie de dire j'ai presque un
boulevard quoi. Ça va donc avec un peu
de moyens, c'est pour ça qu'on on va
lancer cette souscription. Je fais appel
aussi à des messelles. Il y aura sans
doute des investisseurs. On est en train
on va fabriquer, je sais pas quel statut
ça va avoir. Peut-être une coopérative,
peut-être une société anonyme, peut-être
une entreprise de presse solidaire. On
est en train d'y réfléchir. Je veux
vraiment être au point avant de sortir
du bois. Mais je pense que c'est pour ça
qu'il y a cette newsletter qui sort. Je
vais informer au les gens très
régulièrement de de de ce qui se passe
et à un moment donné, on va sortir et on
va refaire euh euh ce que j'aime faire
et ce qu'on sait faire. euh c'est-à-dire
de l'information, une information qui
sera pas la même que celle qu'on a
partout. et euh et et voilà, je je vais
encore abandonner les les livres et la
littérature pour ça. À un moment donné,
quand un sujet va m'habiter plus que
tout, comme ça avait été le cas de Black
Rock, je je le je comment dire, je m'y
remettrai. Mais pour l'instant, vu les
présidentiels qui se profilent, vu le
scénario qu'on nous qu'on nous envoie,
c'est-à-dire ce second tour quasiment
écrit, il faut absolument qu'on qu'on
qu'on change la donne.
Qu'est-ce que tu vas faire au second
tour ? Tu vas faire Castor Junior ou tu
vas t'abstenir ?
Mais j'espère que le second tour sera
pas celui qu'on nous qu'on nous prédit.
Moi, je te parais une bière que Macron
il se représente pas.
Ah bon ?
Tu payes, tu payes ta bière ?
Mais je pense qu' il en avale tellement
que peut-être peut-être pas mais je je
veux bien là. Je pense qu'il va se
représenter moi.
Alors question pas d'internet. Si
question d'internet.
Alors, comment compte-ils diffuser par
les gars femmes par YouTube, par
Pirtube, par Imago ? Non,
changer le schéma classique de
diffusion. on est obligé dans un premier
temps de de passer par YouTube, par
PierreTube aussi, mais on va être sur
Instagram, on va être sur euh euh et on
on va créer un site euh qui va une
application, enfin un smartphone, enfin
on je suis en train vraiment de
travailler avec des développeurs, on
travaille à tout ça et et quand on sera
prêt, c'est pour ça que ça prend un peu
de temps. Je sais que tous les gens sont
pressés que je que je m'y remette et
c'est la première fois que j'en parle
aujourd'hui. C'està dire que j'ai rien
dit jusqu'à présent parce que j'étais
pas sûr de mot enfin j'étais sûr que
j'allais m'y remettre mais là je suis
sûr non seulement de m'y remettre mais
mais on a commencé à y travailler. Donc
quand on sera prêt on va sortir du bois,
on va d'abord lancer cette souscription,
on va sortir des des des programmes,
créer un site et ensuite sans doute en
début d'année, on sera opérationnel.
Euh
ça réagit sur internet, c'est ça ?
Ouais, j'ai j'ai eu les questions. On a
changé le le on a changé notre façon de
prendre les questions sur internet. Donc
là, ça ça me permet en fait de plus me
concentrer sur toi. Donc nous, on te
connaît depuis des années.
Si tu te mets à parler de quelque chose,
c'est que tu es forcément graillé
jusqu'à la moelle.
Bah oui, là je me je m'engage.
Tu as mis des tu as mis des sous de
côté, il y a des sous qui sont dans un
côté.
Pour l'instant, je vais sur ma situation
personnelle, vu ce qu'ils me font subir,
je suis fauché. C'est-à-dire que euh là,
ça fait euh donc j'ai pas de salaire.
Euh je suis au prudom, on fait un
référé. J'espère que le les prudomes
vont les condamner à me à me à à me
verser ce qu'ils me doivent,
c'est-à-dire
un peu un peu d'argent quand même pour
pouvoir tenir. Mais de toute manière, je
je je vais me lancer assez vite et je
sais qu'il y a des y a il y a des tas de
gens qui me proposent de l'argent.
Après, pas à moi personnellement, mais
pour créer ce nouveau média. Donc donc
je je suis assez confiant, mais tout est
à construire. On sait on sait pas ce qui
peut arriver, ce qui va arriver. et
cetera. Mais j'ai vu la générosité de à
la fois des gens. Si si tu voyais les
lettres, c'est d'ailleurs le plus euh le
plus terrible, c'est c'est de voir des
gens qui sont au RSA qui qui filent de
l'argent pour le média, mais pas des
petites sommes, hein. Je j'ai des
lettres de gens qui disent "Voilà, j'ai
donné 250 € euh et vous êtes en train de
de de me voler mon argent." Enfin, c'est
c'est des lettres que j'ai reçu.
Pourquoi ? C'est des gens qui
comprennent pas pourquoi j'aiété viré.
Il y a eu ils doivent être à il y a des
milliers de résiliations en ce moment.
Alors, c'est compliqué de se de de
résilier parce qu'il faut faire des
lettres. Euh, il faut que les lettres
arrivent avant avant une certaine date
et cetera, mais ils sont complètement
affolé en ce moment au médias parce que
de plus en plus de sociaux, alors il y a
des gens qui sont pas informés, les les
cartes bancaires tombent. Eux eux le le
je pense que leur stratégie c'est de se
dire on va tenir ce qu'on va tenir, on
courbe les chines, enfin on courbe le
dos, on attend que l'orage passe et on
va toujours s'en sortir. Mais mais là il
y a une la déflagration est quand même
très forte quoi. Et même enfin moi je
m'attendais pas à ça. C'estd j'ai rien
prémudé réconcilier.
Pardon ?
Vous voulez pas vous réconcilier ?
Bah là moi j'ai j'ai médiateur pour
arranger la situation.
Bah je j'ai essayé enfin ils ils ont une
seule trouille. C'est-à-dire ça a été
écrit. En plus quand il y a eu la
médiation de d'Henry Poulin, moi je leur
ai dit "OK, je peux réfléchir pour
revenir malgré tout." C'est-à-dire que
j'aurais quand même demandé des excuses,
enfin des excuses, une forme d'excuses
pour dire bon ben toutes les accusations
qu'on apporté d'ailleurs il y en a un de
chez eux qui est le l'ancien rédacteur
en chef qui l'a écrit ça. Il l'a il l'a
dit, "J'ai j'ai son SMS quand on lui
pose la question de mais est-ce que
Denis Robert il a il a ça a été un
manager brutal ? Est-ce qu'il a harcelé
? Est-ce qu'il a tenu des propos
racistes ou sexistes et cetera ? Ce ce
rédacteur en chef dit sur Twitter, il
dit "Non, tout ça c'est de l'habillage.
Le vrai problème c'était la règle du 1
pour 3 et cetera." Donc on voit bien
qu'il y a une manipulation derrière tout
ça. Mais le ce que je leur ai dit parce
que moi j'ai joué fran jeu avec
une fois tu trouves qu'il y a une
manipulation,
c'est-à-dire
bah c'est ton point de vue. Je suis
obligé je suis obligé de te dire ça
parce qu'ils sont pas là pour se
défendre.
Oui bien sûr mais tu pourras les
inviter. Enfin tu verras. Enfin je sais
pas si tu as envie. Euh je trouve oui,
la manipulation, elle est elle est
évidente à mes yeux. Euh c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont inventé ces pré formulation,
pardon.
Merci pour cette formulation.
Voilà, des des fois tu vois, je mais je
suis je suis quand même assez blessé. Tu
peux imaginer que que ce que je vis
depuis depuis un mois et demi est est
quand même plutôt douloureux, quoi.
Mais mais non, mais ce que je veux te
dire, c'est c'est tu m'as fait perdre le
fil, c'était c'est que
euh c'est que les les les sociaux enfin
c'est-à-dire que les sociaux euh je sais
plus ce que je voulais dire, tu m'as tu
m'as coupé là,
c'est fait exprès.
Euh on arrive bientôt à la fin de temps,
Non, excuse-moi. c'était la médiation et
que moi j'étais prêt à la à
l'entreprendre cette médiation. Mais
leur peur était que si je reviens à
l'intérieur du truc, comme il y a le
vote de la coopérative avant le 15
décembre, c'estàdire que il y a il y a
une il y a il y a un conseil de
surveillance qui doit être élu, que que
je puisse emporter cette majorité, ce
que j'aurais fait. C'est-à-dire que moi
je veux je veux je veux qu'on qu'on
puisse débattre. J'ai j'étais jusqu'à
salarié de cette boîte et j'avais
j'avais le droit de faire valoir mon
point de vue. Donc là, ils ont ils ont
tout fait pour me censurer. C'est ce que
j'estime.
Merci.
Euh euh et voilà. Et mais parce qu' donc
la médiation ils l'ont interrompu parce
qu'ils ont eu je pense qu'ils ont peur
compte tenu de de de l'appui que j'ai
chez une majorité de sociaux que je
change les les règles à l'intérieur. Ils
ont peur de se faire virer. Ils ont peur
ce que j'ai jamais voulu faire mais bon
voilà l'avenir. Moi je leur souhaite bon
courage. C'estàd que j'ai pas de je je
suis blessé mais je suis pas du tout
haineux en colère envie de régler des
comptes et cetera. Je fais valoir mes
droits, c'est un petit peu normal vu ce
qu'ils m'ont fait subir. Et euh et après
mais je leur souhaite la la la longue
vie quoi. Je leur souhaite de faire du
journalisme, de créer leurs médias,
d'aller où ils veulent avec. J'ai pas de
de d'intention béliqueuse à leur égard,
mais je je ce je ne suis pas l'agressé.
Je ne suis pas l'agresseur. Je suis
l'agressé de depuis depuis un mois et
demi. C'est c'est quand même ça qui se
passe, quoi. Donc à un moment donné, je
te dis, je suis obligé de me défendre.
Un petit mot gentil quand même pour eux.
Bah je te dis, je leur je leur souhaite
je leur souhaite bon courage quoi. Je
leur souhaite de de voilà de de je le
qui qui maintiennent leur activité que
mais mais en ce moment tu tu sais c'est
tu tu connais le bouquin de de Morel qui
s'appelle les les erreurs absurdes. Ça
te dit quelque chose ? C'est un type qui
a étudié par exemple les craqus aériens
et qui essaie de comprendre comment un
pilote d'avion
une chaîne de de décision absurde qui
amène à un craque quoi. Et chaque fois
j'ai j'ai eu le j'ai le sentiment qu'il
y avait souvent une possibilité qu'on
s'en sorte qui qui revienne à une sorte
de principe de réalité et chaque fois
ils prennent la mauvaise décision et que
ça fatalement j'ai peur que ça pour eux
hein que ça arrive à un craque. J'espère
pas. J'espère qu' un moment ils vont pas
Ils ont peut-être ils ont peut-être la
la même perception à ton égard.
Ouais, mais enfin comment dire, j'ai un
peu quelques heures de vol et puis j'ai
quand même j'ai quand même enfin voilà
quoi. Je je suis journaliste, j'écris
des livres, la vie, j'ai pas besoin du
j'ai j'ai jamais eu besoin du média pour
vivre. C'est sans doute la différence
entre la plupart d'entre eux et moi.
C'estd que moi, si je fais ça, c'est par
passion. c'est parce que je crois en
l'information, c'est parce que c'est en
moi. Et et donc voilà, c'est c'est pour
ça que j'étais blessé par par ça et puis
c'est pour ça que je repars à à 100 %
quoi et que je pense que je pense qu'on
va on va bientôt casser la baraque avec
ce qu'on est en train de créer.
On arrive à la fin. Tu connais à chaque
fois un conseil pour les jeunes
générations. Mais avant trois bouquins
pour notre communauté.
Trois bouquins. Alors attends
alors pas le tien
non.
Non non, je vais pas te proposer mes
bouquins mais mais je m'y attendais pas.
Euh ben je vais reprendre le le un
bouquin récent que j'ai lu, c'est celui
de Fabrizio, Calvi, que j'ai trouvé
vraiment intéressant. Après euh
qu'est-ce que j'ai relu cet été ? J'ai
relu Brotigan, donc c'est je reviens
toujours à Brotigan, moi. Euh j'ai relu
Tokyo Montana Express. C'est un un
Brotigan poétique et absolument
merveilleux. Enfin Richard Brotigan, on
a jamais fait mieux. Euh et après euh je
vais lire le livre de ma fille de Loulou
qui s'appelle Zone Grise qui est le
livre le plus courageux que j'ai j'ai lu
sur
le le
sur ce qu'on subir les femmes en ce
moment. Voilà. Et c'est un livre
qui moi m'a
m'a bouleversé. Je suis son père et en
même temps je suis lecteur. S'appelle
Zone Grise. C'est édité chez qui ?
Chez Flamarion.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
et ben de de
d'être d'être courageux, de de
chercher à s'informer parce qu'on dit
souvent que les les mots mais j'ai un
fils de 16 ans qui euh qui il est en
première, il refuse enfin il aime pas
lire, il enf il a il a les archétypes de
tous les mots mais ils sont sur les
réseaux et et tout ça mais j'essaie de
lui faire comprendre que que s'informer
c'est vraiment important et qu'il faut
que qu'il faut qu'il il faut qu'il
résiste
à cette espèce de soupe permanente dans
laquelle on baigne d'information ou ou
tout d'ailleurs, je je le faisais quand
j'étais au média et je le fais moins
aujourd'hui, mais quand tu te lèves le
matin et que tu regardes tu regardes les
chaînes d'info, c'est c'est quand tuas
quand tu as pu regarder la télé pendant
un moment, c'est quand même absolument
édifiant la manière dont dont ça te dont
ça te formate ton ton cerveau quoi. à la
fois chez je vois mon père qui a 85 ans
ou chez mon fils qui a 16 ans, même si
il la regarde pas, il est imprégné de
ça. Tu vois, il y a quelque chose de de
Donc c'est très dur en ce moment pour
ces momes. Moi, j'ai mon fils qui joue
au basket, c'est le sport est vachement
important pour lui. Là, même le basket,
il peut plus en faire. Il peut plus voir
ses copains. Pendant le confinement, il
voyait plus ses copains et cetera. C'est
des c'est des momes qui ont intégré
l'idée
d'une d'une épidémie
et c'est très glaçant pour eux. c'est
ils ont une une ils doivent avoir une
vision du monde. Moi si quand j'avais 15
16 ans parce que ils ont un côté
imperméable, ils déconnent et cetera
mais ça générera une je pense une une
génération de de de personnes
angoissées. On va on va vers des des des
problèmes psychiatriques, de psychose.
J'en ai beaucoup parlé avec des
psychiatres. cette cette période de de
repli sur soi de de on est tous masqués
enfin et cetera, elle euh surtout quand
on on n'est pas encore un adulte formé
enfin où on a un peu de certitude, ils
sont dans un monde dans une dans une
jungle quoi où ils vivent avec Donald
Trump, avec Bolsonaro, avec Macron, avec
Le Pen, avec et il y a peu
d'intelligence là-dedans, il y a peu de
place pour la sagesse, il y a peu de il
y a peu de sérénité. Donc euh donc ça ça
va, tu te dis euh même moi je je je me
dis [__] mais c'est pour ça que c'est
important de faire de l'information,
c'est pour ça et de la faire avec
sérénité, tu vois, de la faire avec
honnêteté, de la de la faire par
passion, tu vois, de de rencontrer des
gens intelligents, de parler avec eux,
de de d'organiser des débats, de de de
se confronter. Quand tu sais pas, tu
sais pas. Il y a des fois, tu vois, tu
me poses des questions, je dis je suis
pas bon en tout quoi. Tu On a pas parlé
de football ou de basket. J'aurais pu.
ni de football ni basket rugby.
Non non mais je déconne. Mais mais tu
vois par rapport à ces à ces gens très
jeunes, j'ai si j'ai si je j'avais une
seule chose à leur dire, c'est la
nécessité absolue de s'informer.
C'està-dire quand il se passe quelque
chose, d'essayer de comprendre, c'est la
clé de tout quoi. S'informer.
C'est pour ça qu'on a créé Syerview et
il nous reste Albert Dupontel.
Ouais.
Denir Robert, merci.
Je te remercie aussi.
Au revoir.
[Musique]